et si vous veniez voir par vous même
qu'est ce qui pousse tout simplement un
apnéiste à vouloir touchées les abymes
le but ultime c'est pas forcément de
gagner des médailles web audio même
c'est d'arriver à gérer ses émotions
dans un certaine orient et c'est un
univers qui nous permet justement
d'aller encore plus loin dans cet état
d'introspection et de travail sur le
corps et aussi sur l'esprit plus on va
être dans l'instant présent et on va
être capable de gérer ce qu'on en a à
faire est concentré sur ce que l'on fait
c'est ta confiance et la capacité à
vivre l'instant présent à être connectés
que sur ce qui se passe sur les sons sur
le toucher sur le ressenti et ça nous
pousse dans les retranchements à changer
des choses dans notre propre vie en
dehors de la cne
[Applaudissements]
le lac le plus vieux du monde les lacs
n'ont généralement pas plus de quinze
mille ans
baykal à plus de 25 millions d'années
ici vivent des esprits et des divinités
bouddhiste
[Musique]
l'eau pure et transparente du lac aide
les scientifiques à résoudre des
mystères de l'univers
je vois le baïkal comme un ensemble
cohérent je ne savais pas à quoi
m'attendre ici ce n'est pas que je
découvre quelque chose de nouveau ici je
m'imprègne simplement de tout ce qu'il y
a
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
pour deux heures d'émission nous
décrypterons comme chaque soir du lundi
au jeudi l'essentiel de l'information
avec nous invités en plateau et nos
reporters sur le terrain voici les
grands titres de l'actualité de ce
mercredi 19 février en syrie l'onu met
en garde contre le péril imminent d'
escalade un conseil de sécurité s'est
tenu ce soir après qu'ankara menacer
damas d'une offensive militaire
imminente dans la province d'idlib la
russie s'opposait déclaration réclamant
un cessez le feu et hausse le ton
vis-à-vis de la turquie aux états unis
premier débat télévisé de la campagne
démocrate ce soir à las vegas le
milliardaire michael bloomberg fait son
entrée dans la course sera-t-il à la
hauteur pour obtenir l'investiture et
des filles et le républicain donald
trump lors de la présidentielle de
novembre
lui se présente en tout cas comme le
candidat capable de rassembler au centre
les dommages collatéraux de la sphère
griveaux avec ce règlement de comptes
entre anciens amis le patron du ps
olivier faur accuse le ministre de
l'intérieur christophe castaner d'avoir
commis une faute grave en cause des
vocations de sa vie privée à la radio
olivier faur demande à emmanuel macron
d'en tirer des conséquences entre temps
christophe castaner exprimé ses regrets
et l'examen de la réforme des retraites
vire au blocage à l'assemblée nationale
au troisième jour des débats les rappels
au règlement et suspensions se succèdent
quant à la cgt elle claque la porte des
discussions de la conférence sur le
financement ce que déplore l'exécutif
[Musique]
doit-on craindre une escalade dans le
nord-ouest de la syrie ce soir moscou
s'est opposé à l'onu une déclaration
réclamant un cessez le feu
la turquie de son côté menace damas
d'une opération militaire imminente sur
ils livrent depuis plusieurs semaines
les milices soutenues par ankara
affrontent l'armée de bachar el assad
la tension est donc montée d'un cran
après le décès de militaires turcs après
des bombardements syrien à ces menaces
interviennent alors que la russie allié
damas mène des négociations avec ankara
pour faire baisser justement les
tensions les discussions vaines pour le
président turc de son côté le kremlin
met en garde contre toute opération
visant bachar el assad où nous entrons
dans les derniers jours pour le régime
qui doit cesser son offensive à idlib et
se retirer aux frontières de l'accord de
sotchi c'est notre dernière mise en
garde
malheureusement ni les discussions
menées dans notre pays et en russie ni
les négociations menées sur le terrain
ne nous ont permis d'obtenir le résultat
que nous voulons pour le dire d'une
manière plus explicite
une opération à idlib est imminente nos
amis turcs n'ont pas réussi à séparer
les militants qui leur sont soumises des
terroristes dans le délai mentionné par
le mémorandum de septembre 2018
ils n'ont pas réussi à le faire un an
plus tard
dans le même temps des provocations
depuis la zone d'idlib ont toujours lieu
ainsi que des bombardements visant les
positions des forces armées syriennes
des sites civils et la base aérienne
russe de même naturellement les forces
armées syriennes
tout en réitérant leur attachement à
l'accord initial y compris l'accord de
cessez-le-feu répondre à ces
provocations inacceptables et nous les
soutenons
l'émissaire de l'onu pour la série met
donc en garde aujourd'hui le conseil de
sécurité de l'onu contre un péril
imminent d'escaladé dans le nord-ouest
de la syrie écouter les délégations
russe et turc se sont réunis à plusieurs
reprises au cours des derniers jours à
ankara munich et moscou il ya également
eu des contacts au niveau des présidents
mais aucun accord à ce stade n'a encore
été conclu tout au contraire les
déclarations publiques des différentes
parties syriennes et internationales
l'est entendre un risque imminent
d'escaladé pour en parler avec claude
maison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir claude
blanchemaison merci d'être avec nous
première question qui l'objectif
poursuit le président turc arnaud and
mais je crois que pour simplifier on
pourrait dire qu'il a quatre objectifs
naturellement le premier très générale
c'est d'établir que la turquie est
devenue un pays incontournable pour
toutes les questions de la de la région
la deuxième le deuxième objectif c'est
la sphère des réfugiés de la poste la
poche d'idlib
la turquie a déjà sur le territoire turc
3 million et demi de réfugiés syriens et
ce qui se passe actuellement à et
dribbler bombardements font que neuf
cent mille habitants de la zone se sont
déplacés vers la frontière turque ihh
pour rien à voir deux millions trois
millions et ça pour la turquie c'est
complètement inacceptable
troisième élément la turquie lorsque les
américains se sont retirés a fait beau
mouvement un mouvement militaire le
le long de la frontière syrienne et en
syrie et a repris le contrôle d'une
partie du territoire syrien qui était
occupé par des combattants kurdes qui se
battait d'ailleurs avec les occidentaux
et la russie à modérer un peu cette
action mais a dans le fond installé là
la turquie dans une zone tampon qui se
trouve situé au nord de la syrie et
erdogan veut pouvoir négocier peut-être
même il l'a dit implanter des réfugiés
syriens dans cette zone là donc il prend
il prend position et puis enfin
évidemment il ya l'aspect politique
intérieure pour lui ça permet de
susciter un mouvement nationaliste en
turquie pour peut-être faire oublier
certains déboires en matière économique
et sociale
alors évidemment la la la nature qui n'a
probablement pas les moyens de mener une
véritable guerre contre la syrie
d'abord tout simplement parce que c'est
la russie qui contrôlent l'espace aérien
de la tuerie et que par conséquent sa
limite tout à fait les possibilités
d'action et puis on peut penser que en
effet erdogan cherche à dans le fond
c'est comme s'il disait retenez moi ou
je fais un malheur
voilà donc il a il met tout sur la table
en faisant penser qu'il est en état
d'intervenir militairement
ce qui n'est pas absolument certain
alors ça c'est pour les l'objectif est
effectivement de la turquie l'objectif
de bachar el assad
bachar el-assad c'est toujours le même
c'est à dire que bien entendu il veut
recouvrait
le contrôle de l'intégralité du
territoire de la syrie et il ya deux
parties qui échappent qui lui échappe
actuellement la région d'idlib où sont
stationnés un certain nombre de
combattants qui ont été retirés de zones
d escalade qui sont et qui se trouvait
ailleurs en syrie
et puis la fameuse zone tampon
d'ailleurs et par conséquent et il
voudra tôt ou tard retrouver le contrôle
de ces zones alors évidemment l'argument
c'est de dire dans la zone 10 doubles il
était convenu que les turcs désarmerait
les rebelles
ce qui n'a pas aidé les faits et les
rebelles tirent sur les troupes
syriennes à la russie dans ces
conditions à ce qu'elle peut rester
larbitre de la situation larbitre je ne
sais pas mais sans doute un régulateur
et un modérateur
parce que évidemment la syrie est
l'alliée de la russie et la russie va
protéger la syrie mais la russie n'a pas
non plus intérêt à déclencher une
véritable catastrophe humanitaire et a
déclenché un déferlement de plus de deux
millions de réfugiés syriens sur la
turquie
ce qui créerait probablement une
réprobation internationale
alors c'est probablement ce qui fait
l'intérêt de la saisine du conseil de
sécurité aujourd'hui
alors justement conseil de sécurité à
l'onu ce soir qui s'est achevée à
l'heure qu'il est qu'est ce qu'on peut
en attendre comme résultat évidemment
c'est d'abord un jeu rôle c'est à dire
que dans le jeu de rôle les américains
soutiennent la turquie mais ils la
soutiennent verbalement les américains
se sont retirés
ils ne vont pas intervenir militairement
les russes soutiennent leur allié syrien
et puis les français
on sent une catastrophe humanitaire une
urgence humanitaire
que fait-on que peut-on faire pour les
trois millions de personnes qui sont
dans la région d'idlib dans la poche
d'idlib et effectivement le mérite de la
saisine du conseil de sécurité c'est que
peut-être ça va dépendre des deux
ultimes conclusions le conseil de
sécurité pourrait re discuter de cette
question dans quelques jours de façon à
ce que la tension retombée à modérer les
ardeurs de monsieur erdogan
le péril imminent d' escalade que craint
l'onu l'émissaire de l'onu en syrie
est-ce qu'on veut craignait aussi oui il
est réel et est d'autant plus que dans
ces cas là tout peut déraper à tout
moment mais il me semble que dans son
rôle de modérateur
la russie peut probablement calmé le jeu
pour cela il faut en effet arrêter
l'offensive syrienne sur la zone dite
libre
et puis négocier continuer la
négociation qui a été engagée avec les
turcs pour trouver une solution sûre
pour les populations qui sont la zone iv
mais aussi pour la zone tampon qui se
trouve au nord merci beaucoup
claude blanchemaison d'avoir été avec
nos experts en relations internationales
merci à vous aux etats unis à présent le
milliardaire michael bloomberg a fera
son entrée en piste ce soir face à ses
rivaux démocrates pour tenter d'obtenir
l'investiture à la présidentielle
premier débat télévisé pour celui qui se
présente comme le candidat capable de
rassembler au centre retour sur son
ascension fulgurante avec clémence pital
les analystes politiques ne lui donnait
aucune chance
pourtant trauma plus tard michael
bloomberg en course à l'investiture
démocrate à bondy en troisième position
des sondages et on tombe bien des pieds
donald trump
je me présente pour vaincre donald trump
j'avais averti dans mon discours à la
convention démocrate en 2016 à
philadelphie que 2 valve trucks n'était
pas apte à occuper cette fonction
et il est bien pire que ce que j'avais
imaginé pour rattraper son retard
l'ancien maire de new york a dépensé
sans compter
plus de 400 millions de dollars dans une
campagne publicitaire devenu presque
omniprésente dans le pays
de quoi inquiéter ses concurrents alors
qu'il talonne les favoris démocrate joe
biden et bernie sanders ses adversaires
ou double leurs attaques
il accuse ainsi le septuagénaire de
chercher à jeter la présidentielle est
dénoncée choix politiques parfois très
conservateur monsieur bloomberg
vous n'allez certainement pas gagner
lorsqu'on sait qu'à new york vous avez
mené une politique raciste tels que le
stop en friche
et oblige des communautés minoritaires
les afro américains et latino américain
à vivre dans la peur et l'humiliation
dans la ville de new york
vous n'avez pas gagné d'élection si vous
opposé à l'augmentation du salaire
minimum
vous savez les gens qui ont des
milliards de dollars ne devrait pas
s'opposer une augmentation du salaire
minimum ou dessus de 7 $ 25 de leur île
charge de sanders alors que le
milliardaire n'a cessé d'osciller entre
les familles démocrate et républicaine
au gré de ses ambitions politiques
michael bloomberg est poursuivi par sa
politique de contrôles policiers
systématiques de stopper ce risque
décision qu'il a déploré deux semaines
avant de se lancer dans la course à la
présidentielle
il ya une approche que je regrette
profondément la vue d'une pratique
policière appelée stop and fisc gelé
défendu pendant trop longtemps car je ne
comprenais pas alors la douleur à
justifier qu'elles causaient aux jeunes
familles noires et métisses ainsi qu'à
leurs enfants
j'aurais dû agir plus tôt et plus
rapidement pour y mettre fin
je n'ai pas fait et je me suis excusé
alors que michael bloomberg entend
rassembler l'électorat démocrate modérée
la course à l'investiture semble encore
très ouverte
le médiateur va participer aujourd'hui à
son premier débat dans le nevada état où
sera organisé samedi le troisième vote
pour la primaire et pour en parler nous
sommes avec à françois durpaire
historien spécialiste des états unis
bonsoir françois roy accord doit
s'attendre ce soir un débat houleux
selon vous oui parce qu'en fait tout le
monde peut encore gagner alors faut se
dire que c'est pas un débat général
c'est pas un débat national c'est un
débat où on a les yeux tournés vers le
nevada vers la prochaine édition
donc on va vraiment aimé vallat c'est
assez ouvert parce qu'on n'a pas
énormément de sondages
traditionnellement c'est un état on a
peu de son image et où effectivement
c'est assez ouvert c'est à dire qu'on
n'a pas encore ce duel tant annoncé
on a effectivement un candidat qui est
favori parce que il est bien maintenant
une avance à deux chiffres il a 31 %
c'est sanders mais en même temps il est
socialiste
est-ce que ça va aller jusqu'au bout
c'est quand même assez étonnant puis
alors évidemment l'inconnue de la nuit
c'est l'arrivée de bloomberg dans la
course c'est la première fois qu'on va
le voir le milliardaire l'homme qui
valait 50 7 milliards de dollars c'est
c'est ça qui va être intéressant parce
que dépenser d'argent est une chose
faire des pubs pré enregistré et balancé
à la télé à la radio 300 millions $
quand même dépensé c'est une chose mais
être en débat c'en est une autre
donc là on va voir comment bloomberg va
se comporter face aux autres sachant que
lui sera pas dans ce débat-là ils
attendent super tuesday
il a fait l'impasse sur les màj comme
aux sports il commence pas la course il
attend il attend les finales les demi
finales et la finale
alors c'est pas un novice quand même et
qu'elle en looberghe vite voilà le débat
c'est autre chose mais c'est un homme
rompu qui a de l'expérience
est-ce qu'il peut créer selon vous la
surprise oui alors pour est
effectivement d'abord ce que vous avez
dit il a de l'expérience faut quand même
voir qu'il a dirigé pendant douze ans
une ville new york qui et c'est
l'économie de la corée du sud
ces deux
quasiment je crois en ses 70 milliards
de budget donc c'est plus que 40 états
américains donc c'est vraiment même si
généralement on ne devient pas président
après avoir été maire on va avoir été
plutôt gouverneur ou sénateurs donc une
expérience c'est son premier atout
deuxième atout c'est que c'est une sorte
de 30
il va prendre 30 à son propre jeu
d'abord ce qui est beaucoup plus riche
que lui qui peut dépenser encore plus
d'argent et écrivez excusez-moi de cette
phrase il est il et il est ok sur la
politique sale cirque jusqu'à maintenant
trump on le prend toujours par le haut
vous soulevez la phrase de michèle obama
qui conseillait à tous les démocrates
ils vont essayer watts et golo we go à
et ouais quand ils font quelque chose de
bas quand ils font quelque chose de la
hauteur alors oui pas du tout lui il va
prendre trump avec les gants de boxe
vous souvenez de cette image il a déjà
dit moi j'ai pas peur avec ces faux
cheveux et son et son et soi et son
bronzage vaporiser il me fait pas peur
donc on va avoir à quelque chose d'assez
d'assez physique il est capable de le
prendre à son propre jeu
et puis et puis la dernière peut-être
dernier atout c'est que c'est son
positionnement
vous savez quand il ya une économie
aussi florissante on est au milieu de la
phase d'expansion la plus importante de
l'histoire des états unis
c'est difficile d'arriver en disant on
va changer tout on va transformer le
changement c'est maintenant non alors
lui c'est intéressant parce qu'il va pas
d'idées on ne va pas dire le changement
c'est maintenant il va dire on continue
tout l'économie je suis un homme
d'affaires je l'homme de wall street etc
en revanche vous propose un agent sur le
style or quand on regarde les américains
les sondages c'est oui on aime le job de
deux ans n'aime pas trop son style donc
là ils ont peut-être à donald trump sans
le style de 20 trains pirates là vous
m'avez fait parler des atouts un oui
j'espère ici des mondes ne vous
inquiétez pas j'allais y venir alors
quelles sont justement les choses qu'on
peut lire prochaines heures
bernie sanders a déjà commencé
injustement attaquée sur l'argent
c'est ça s'empire son pirate ou sans
piscine sans qu'un défaut je vais vous
dire stéphanie sait il n'est pas
démocrate
c'est un concept la majorité des
démocrates de considère comme un
républicain et un démocrate modéré qui
pourrait faire le pendant de sanders qui
serait le démocrate gauchiste mais ils
se disent mais qu'est ce qu'il a
vraiment de démocrates
alors évidemment le gros problème c'est
que trump il a gagné des états qui sont
des états démocrates des états gauche il
a gagné luis win thin la pennsylvanie et
le michigan pour un démocrate faudrait
reconquérir l'ouvrier aurait calé le
démocrate moins bien placé pour
reconquérir les ouvriers l'homme de wall
street de deuxième chose il case il
coche
aucune des autres cases les jeunes non
les minorités non plus les femmes non
plus pour des raisons x ou y
on va pas revenir son sexisme ses propos
etc et puis il ya aussi une casserole
c'est que tranquille il fait très bien
sur le patriotisme économique c'est sako
fonctionner chez lui or vous savez que
bloomberg lp son entreprise fait tous
les ans une conférence sur la chine où
la chine est formidable et c'est quand
vous demandez aux américains aujourd'hui
la menace et qui sait la chine et et lui
sa dernière conférence il a fait à pékin
pour dire tout le bien qu'ils pensaient
l'économie chinoise et pour dire
également le parti communiste écoute la
population chinoise et s'adonne altran
va lui sortir en débat ainsi c'est donc
il a quand même un certain nombre de
handicaps qui font que c'est pas gagné
quand même alors senders bloomberg les
autres ça y est vous les savez relégué
déjà ou non
je les regrette pas parce que le peuple
américain ne les a pas reléguer on est
encore dans une campagne démocrate
d'abord sanders et 13 en tête mais crise
et démocrates
il ya une proportionnelle ça veut dire
que on a le fameux 1991 c'est pas une
date c'est le nombre de délégués pour
l'emporter
eh bien il va avoir du mal à les avoir
parce que c'est toujours à la
proportionnelle et même un gars comme
bas
dunn qui a été en tête des sondages
nationaux pendant très longtemps
si dans le nevada bientôt il est en
gagne alors lambaye donne pour l'instant
ça va pas du tout mais je me demandais
ce que je les cartes sont les cas là là
on a un grand favori sanders messenger
c'est quand même un problème chez les
démocrates y lire que sanders candidat
c'est un programme assez un problème
parce que le le américain moyen il voit
quoi en sanders ou dit le socialisme
c'est pas l'idéologie qui pose un
problème
il se dit par contre mes impôts ou
est-ce que ça va pas remonter c'est
quand même sanders eu quand même ça pose
problème à l'américain moyen
et si sanders n'est pas candidat c'est
peut-être encore plus un problème parce
que l'on fait quoi des voix de sanders
pour l'instant l'électorat démocrate il
vote sanders vous rappeler que sanders
il a fait en partie la défaite d'hillary
clinton
parce qu'il n'a pas reporté ses voix sur
hillary clinton
enfin les américains n'ont pas voté ceux
qui avaient voté s'inverse n'ont pas
voté majoritairement clinton et s'il est
en tête alors ce sera encore pire
l'establishment pourra pas expliqué
qu'il faudra mettre bloomberg vous
faudra mettre quelqu'un d'autre donc on
peut avoir à la convention des supers
délégués qui seraient du côté
effectivement de quelqu'un un peu
modérer centriste mais avec un fond
d'électorat démocrate qui serait très à
gauche et ça ça serait et là évidemment
comment vous dire ça serait du petit
lait c'est le rêve éveillé pour donald
trump de garder ma important ce soir
pour cette course à l'investiture
démocrate
ouais il faut manquer aucun épisode de
la série
donald trump et la réélection en
novembre prochain
ça va être évidemment intéressant un
débat intéressant et qui va nous amener
vers le nevada est évidemment manquera
pas le 3 mars prochain avec le concours
avec le décalage horaire se lever tôt
oui merci beaucoup
avec la situation libye au coeur des
préoccupations internationales le
ministre russe de la défense sergueï
choïgou a reçu aujourd'hui le maréchal
khalifa haftar opposants au gouvernement
d'union nationale reconnue par les
nations unies celui-ci annoncé ne plus
participer aux pourparlers de genève
il estime que les forces du haftar ont
violé des très fragile mise en place en
janvier dernier un événement qui
pourrait bien remettre en cause tous les
efforts diplomatiques de ces derniers
mois le pays est en crise depuis
maintenant plusieurs années les îles à
saraf avec jandy demory le gouvernement
libyen d'union nationale a annoncé dans
la nuit de mardi à mercredi la
suspension de sa participation aux
travaux d'une commission conjointe
militaire à genève qui comprend
également des représentants du maréchal
haftar cette décision a été prise à la
suite notamment de tirs de roquettes ce
mardi contre le port de tripoli sous le
contrôle du gn 1 et ce malgré l'entrée
en vigueur mi janvier d'un cessez-le-feu
peu respectée alors que la situation sur
le terrain reste une situation où la
trêve est très fragile
de nouvelles attaques ont lieu
aujourd'hui sur le port de tripoli où
des incidents se produisent un peu
partout
la situation ne change pas non pas
personne n'a jusqu'à présent renier le
principe d' acceptation de la trêve le
processus politique essaie de trouver un
moyen d'aller de l'avant
face à cette situation le ministre russe
de la défense sergueï choïgou a reçu ce
mercredi le maréchal haftar selon un
communiqué du ministère les deux hommes
ont discuté de la situation en libye
du rôle important de négociation
organisé à moscou en janvier et de la
nécessité de remplir les conditions
fixées lors d'une conférence
internationale à berlin
lundi l'union européenne a sacrifié la
mission de surveillance lancée en 2015
au large de la libye
une nouvelle sera programmée
prochainement pour empêcher les
livraisons d'armes aux deux camps qui
s'affrontent dans le pays
le nom sofia faudrait ça n'existe plus
donc nous avons quand même trouvé un
accord politique
un agrément politique sur le futur pense
que nous avons tous commenté c'est
formidable on est maintenant sur le
niveau de des nations unies et fans
locaux allaient dans la bonne direction
tripoli est depuis près d'un an la cible
d'une offensive lancée par l'armée
nationale libyenne une opération
destinée notamment à combattre les
groupes terroristes et les milices
armées présents dans la région
seul un accord pour un cessez-le-feu
stable garantirez la tenue du sommet
politique prévue le 26 février prochain
et pour michel scarbonchi consultant en
relations internationales ancien député
européen la présence militaire turc en
libye a renforcé le soutien de la
population au maréchal afta monsieur
erdogan a fait une erreur en annonçant
l'envoi de troupes turques
ce qui n'a pas fait d'ailleurs ils
envoyaient des conseillers des officiers
mais ne pas envoyer de troupes il
envoyer des mini syrienne en faisant
cette annonce
il a dressé contre lui l'ensemble de la
population libyenne c'est à dire même
les tribus qui était pas proche de stars
ou même les in thani et cetera qu'était
neutre ou qui bougeait pas se sont
ralliés contre l'ennemi extérieur contre
l'envahisseur ottoman se sont ralliés
haftar il a fait une faute il a soudé
autour du maréchal haftar l'ensemble de
la population libyenne et les tensions
entre l'iran et les états unis se
poursuivent le bras de fer américano
iranien ont toujours aussi intense mec
pompéo le secrétaire d'état américain
s'est prononcé en faveur
de nouvelles discussions avec l'iran à
condition d'un changement de
comportement une réponse son homologue
iranien mohammed jawad arif il veut
forcer les états unis à revenir à la
table des négociations et des rapports à
distance toujours aussi tendues entre
les deux pays les etats-unis sont prêts
à parler avec l'iran à tout moment mais
le régime iranien doit changer
fondamentalement son comportement
dynamique
c'est le moment de dire aux états unis
que leur politique de pression maximale
a échoué si vous voulez donner plus de
pouvoirs à mes collègues dans le domaine
de la politique étrangère jusqu'à ce
qu'il puisse mettre fin aux sanctions
plus sérieusement nous devons forcer des
états unis à revenir à la table des
négociations
mob bayadh omnikron non pas par une
négociation bilatérale mais la
négociation que les états unis ont
laissé dans quelques instants nous
parlerons du dossier des retraites la
cgt a décidé de quitter la conférence de
financement et puis nous reviendrons sur
les suites de la sphère griveaux et dans
son sillage les propos de christophe
castaner sur la vie privée du patron du
ps olivier faure qui lui dénonce une
faute grave
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
coups politiques n'a jamais été obligé
de dire la veille les idées courageuse
des mots qui comptent en soi vient de
l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on est une gauche
extrêmement tous les témoins de notre
époque sont dans la grande interview
les tueurs professionnels utilisent des
révolvers il tire deux fois par ici et
par là je m'appelle presque espace
caisse pop et j'étais le tueur de
confiance de pablo escobar j'ai tué plus
de 250 personnes de mes propres mains
je suis tueur professionnel je tuais
pour de l'argent j'ai tué aussi par
amour et respect pour la blu escobar
avec j'aime la douleur j'ai un seuil de
douleur élevé alors je suis un homme
très religieux je suis un guerrier
j'adore le seigneur le saint-esprit ne
pouvions donc pas les humilier respect
nous leur avons tiré deux balles dans la
tête
ensuite nous les avons des membres et
est brûlé ma part les malfrats s'est
tuée et poser des bombes et facile pour
moi je suis un expert en terrorisme
kidnapping et crimes de toutes sortes
je voulais simplement tuer pour le
compte de pablo escobar on est des êtres
humains
je vous emmène découvrir les robots les
plus high tech qui vont bientôt sortir
de leur laboratoire pour rentrer dans
nos maisons
après l'escale
[Musique]
je
hu l'air des robots approche nous avons
l'opportunité de pouvoir changer le
monde
ceux-ci excitant ils vont changer notre
manière de nous divertir d'apprendre le
communiqué en fait ils vont changer
notre vie
[Musique]
dans le sport l'institution du sport
pourquoi est-elle défaillante dans l'eau
ce moment il ya quand même deux fois
plus d'agressions sexuelles pendant dans
le monde hors sport faut les prédateurs
sexuels c'est plus est ces pratiques le
monde du sport parce qu'ils savent
sinistre vers le toucher berlin team de
la tête
au fil des années on voit bien que la
place de l'entraîneur est de plus en
plus prégnante est importante au sein du
sport aujourd'hui c'est une figure qui
est central dans l'écosystème c'est
c'est vraiment quelqu'un qui est souvent
sacralisé biya aussi la domination
adultes enfants il faut se prendre par
la main il faut travailler il fait il
faut accompagner les athlètes
il faut il faut les accompagner
juridiquement psychologiquement
médicalement socialement c'est pas de
l'hystérie c'est pas un buzz c'est la
réalité
noumea malin ce qui est le fondement du
sport à savoir ses valeurs
[Musique]
la rivière tout beau et chaud
au delà du cours moyen
et elle s'est inclinée pour saluer le
propriétaire du tout menace en
traditionnel et à la demande et fait
cesser cette tempête de neige sinon mon
peuple mourra
[Musique]
un bonsoir à tous bienvenue suis raté
france 20h30 heure française l'assemblée
nationale poursuit ou plutôt tente de
poursuivre ses débats sur le projet de
réforme des retraites sur les plus de
quarante mille amendements déposés en
majorité par la france aux mises et les
communistes les députés n'ont étudié que
quelques 80 d'entre eux tous ont été
rejetés
et cette bataille ouverte entre majorité
et opposition va encore durer au moins
deux semaines deux semaines s'y mettent
ndahi la porte parole du gouvernement
reste évasif quand l utilisation du 49 3
comme vous le savez le 49-3 est un outil
constitutionnel et à ce stade la
constitution n'a pas bougé sauf erreur
de ma part la volonté du gouvernement
est évidemment que nous puissions avoir
un débat un débat qui soit le plus
serein possible mais vous aurez remarqué
qu'il n'est pas de notre fait mais de
celui de la france est soumise et du
groupe gdr à l'assemblée nationale qu'il
y ait cette forme d'obstruction qui au
fond ne sert pas vraiment le débat et
qui conduit y compris à ce qu'il y ait
des prises de positions étonnantes
notamment de la part de la france
insoumise lorsque nous trouvons des
amendements de suppression pour qu'il
n'y ait pas de minimum de pension
accordée aux retraités en france
il ya un certain nombre d'organisations
politiques qui ne souhaite pas qu'il y
ait un débat et qui souhaitent
simplement empêcher que cette réforme
puisse avoir lieu
et même empêché un débat démocratique
qui contribuent à éclairer nos
concitoyens de manière collective
mais l'opposition continue de contester
cette réforme des retraites marine le
pen jean-luc mélenchon ou encore nicolas
dupont aignan ils évoquent eux aussi le
recours aux 49 3 écoutez c'est à dire
que dans un moment si vous le
gouvernement apparaît autant en décalage
avec les
aspiration des français winnie le fait
que chacun connaît aujourd'hui à savoir
que la majorité des français sont
opposés à cette réforme des retraites
donc ils gouvernent contre le peuple
français
si évidemment il passe par le 49-3 alors
même que déjà le recours à 29 ordonnance
est un abus manifeste bien entendu je
pense que ce sera entendu par les
français comme un nouvel acte de
d'autoritarisme
si vous dites universelles à propos
d'une disposition du régime des
retraites ou que vous dites vous
utiliser le mot universel
à propos d'un autre aspect je ne sais
pas moi le bordereau de pour servir les
retraites c'est toujours le même mot
mais on parle pas du même sujet ils
veulent que ce soit le chaos et qu'on
puisse dire c'est l'opposition qui a
créé le chaos donc 49 3 ou 7 49 3 il ya
pas beaucoup de pays où ça existe un
truc pareil hein je voudrais rappeler à
tout le monde ce que ça veut dire le
gouvernement dit article 49 3 si vous
n'avez pas de majorité contre le
gouvernement salue le texte est adopté
c'est une méthode imaginez vous fassiez
ça dans votre vie mais avec n'importe
clients autour de vous c'est ou bien
c'est comme j'ai dit et si la personne
contre ben bref
non je crois qu'il prépare ça je ne
comprends pas le le président ferrand
est devenu agressif teigneux
je pense qu'il a dû recevoir des
consignes on a dû lui dire ne laisse pas
recommencer la sphère benalla non mais
ce qui se passe est ahurissant mais je
je j'ai déposé une centaine
d'amendements donc je ne suis pas celui
qui dépose des milliers d'amendements
mais on n'a pas le droit on n'a jamais
vu un président de l'assemblée nationale
se comportait comme un chef de parti
voilà la réalité le président de
l'assemblée nationale outrepasse ses
droits et s'appuie sur une décision du
conseil constitutionnel en
l'interprétant à sa façon et en
exagérant son pouvoir
on est dans une rupture de démocratie
jamais vu jamais vu jamais vu je suis
parlementaire depuis un certain temps je
n'ose pas dire le nombre d'années je
n'ai jamais vu ça jamais ils font porter
sur le groupe communiste
le poids de leur haine de classe leur
volonté de déchirer ce qui fait le socle
de la protection sociale à la française
nous prenons la tacc contre les
parlementaires communistes puisqu'ils ne
balayent nos amendements comme la légion
d'honneur dont nous sommes fiers
les libéraux ont choisi leurs
adversaires et bien les adversaires vont
résister en séance article par article
amendement par amendement et nous allons
ils ont décidé de pourrir nos retraites
nous allons leur pourrir le débat et
côté syndical alors que la conférence de
financement vient seulement de débuter
la cgt keep la table des négociations
katrina père est numéro deux du syndicat
l'a annoncé ce matin sur radio classique
elle évoque un compromis impossible une
annonce à laquelle a aussitôt réagi
laurent aux piètres à 16 qui le
secrétaire d'état chargé des retraites
la conférence des financements est morte
le compromis n'est pas possible on n'a
plus rien à faire à cette conférence des
financements par contre on va organiser
notre propre conférence
il n'y a pas que la cgt dans le paysage
syndical français
je regrette toujours que les partenaires
sociaux veulent pas au bout des temps
des opportunités qui leur sont offertes
et pour henri sterdyniak économiste au
centre de recherche en économie de
sciences po membres des économistes
atterrés il serait intéressant de voir
comme le gouvernement va recevoir les
suggestions de la cfdt
disons que cette conférence de
financement n'avait pas grand sens pour
la seiche la cgt puisque le gouvernement
l'avait organisé avec le diktat qu' il
fallait absolument que les partenaires
sociaux se trouvent se mettent d'accord
pour récupérer 12 milliards en 2017 à
2027 l'évaluation que le gouvernement
faisait du déficit prévisible dans la
mesure où la cgt estime que ce déficit
prévisible n'existe pas dans la mesure
où la cgt n'est pas prêt à prendre des
mesures a préconisé des mesures pour
réduire
les retraites ou pour retarder l'âge de
départ à la retraite pour économiser ses
12 milliards effectivement la cgt avait
pas grand chose à faire dans cette
conférence il faut voir quels seront les
suggestions que va faire la cfdt et
comment le gouvernement va les recevoir
jusqu'à présent le gouvernement est
ferme sur une position
trouvez-moi 12 milliards et trouver
moins 12 milliards sans augmenter les
cotisations et trouvez-moi 12 milliards
sont sans baisser les pensions la seule
solution que voile gouvernement c'est
retarder l'âge de départ à la retraite
maintenant la cfdt peut avoir d'autres
propositions par exemple en 2025 on a à
rembourser la dette sociale donc ça veut
dire que en 2024
on va rembourser 24 milliards aux
marchés financiers est pas peu dire
l'année suivante c'est 24 milliards ils
vont servir à combler le déficit
éventuel des retraites et même une
restreinte qui vous pour financer la
dépendance
et par ailleurs il ya une grande partie
de ce déficit qui est dû au fait que le
gouvernement annonce qu'il va baisser le
nombre de fonctionnaires qui va pas
augmenter
'l'indice de traitements de la fonction
publique y a qu'à dire au gouvernement
renoncé à baisser le nombre de
fonctionnaires on peut facilement
augmenter le nombre de fonctionnaires
dans les hôpitaux ou à la police ou à la
justice
indexé correctement l' indice du point
de la fonction publique il y aura pas de
déficit
le but du gouvernement foncièrement
c'est de baisser le poids des retraites
dans le pib le coût le le gouvernement
sait que il va y avoir 25% de retraités
en plus et il présente un projet de loi
dans lequel il dit
la part des retraites dans le pipe va
baisser de 13,8 à 12,9
il va falloir d'une façon ou d'une autre
réduire le montant des retraites et il
va falloir retarder l'âge de départ à la
retraite et le gouvernement ne veut pas
céder sur ces deux points et donc
ensuite on demande aux partenaires
sociaux de
de bavarder foncièrement le gouvernement
ne change pas ses deux objectifs c'est
un bavardage et puis ça a un avantage
c'est que les résultats couronnent le
gouvernement a déposé un projet de loi
avec un article 57 qui nous dit le
l'article 57 va dépendre des résultats
de la conférence de financement et donc
ça permet au gouvernement de gagner du
temps on ne sait pas si oui ou non dans
le projet de loi y aura l'idée de douar
philippe sur lequel il va falloir
travailler jusqu'à 64 ans dès 2000 27
pour avoir une retraite au taux plein et
on le saura que dans trois mois une fois
que les députés auront voté une première
fois la loi
on va rajouter un article supplémentaire
c'est du point de vue de la démocratie
parlementaire c'est quand même tout à
fait extravagants je pense que compte
tenu de le gouvernement ne veut pas
céder le gouvernement a une majorité
tout à fait garanti à l'assemblée
nationale donc l'opposition a choisi une
méthode d'obstruction et dont il ya un
blocage total de gouvernement va en
sortir par le 49-3 qui horrible puisque
ça veut dire que il va imposer ses vues
et qu'il y aura aucun moyen pour les
différentes professions concernées
d'aménager le texte par l'intermédiaire
d'amendements raisonnable qui aurait pu
être porté par les députés et donc c'est
disons l'obstination qui du gouvernement
est également la riposte choisi par
françaises soumises qui vont aboutir à
la situation le pire la pire
c'est-à-dire un texte mal pensée mal
conçu qui va passer sans examen
parlementaire
mais le statut de réfugié de piotr
pawlinski peut-il être remis en cause
c'est non pour les services du ministère
de l'intérieur pour
les éléments reprochés à l'artiste russe
ne peuvent être regardés comme
justifiant un retrait du statut le
ministre castetner lui juge au contraire
que le gouvernement pourrait remettre en
cause le statut de piotr paszkowski l
issue de la procédure judiciaire
une déclaration ce matin chez nos
confrères de france inter
les éléments reprochés à piotr pawlenty
ne peuvent être regardés comme
justifiant un retrait du statut au sens
de l'article l7 son 11-6 du code de
l'entrée et du séjour des étrangers et
du droit d'asile
ce que j'attends d'eux quelqu'un que
l'on protège dans le cadre d'un statut
de réfugié politique
c'est qu'effectivement ils sont un
citoyen exemplaire s'il est sanctionné
nous pourrons remettre en cause son
statut de réfugié à ce moment là alors
peut-on parler de la vie privée des
hommes et des femmes politiques ou s
contre les principes du débat public
c'est la question que le numéro un du
parti socialiste
olivier faure a soulevé cet après midi
lors d'une conférence de presse ce
dernier a réagi aux propos de christophe
castaner tenus plus tôt dans la journée
les précisions de cyrielle bourriche
entendu c'est mercredi entre olivier
faure et le ministre de l'intérieur
christophe castaner en cause une
déclaration du premier secrétaire du
parti socialiste ce lundi au micro de
france inter au sujet de la sphère
griveaux c'est la preuve d'une légèreté
incroyable parce qu'aujourd'hui quand
vous êtes un homme ou une femme publique
un décideur public
un ministre vous devez prendre toutes
les précautions d'usagé pour ne jamais
être à la portée des maîtres chanteurs
déclaration qui a déplu au ministre de
l'intérieur
ce dernier a riposté sur cette même
matinal ce mercredi matin en évoquant
directement à l'antenne la vie privée du
premier secrétaire du parti socialiste
les politiques doivent rester des femmes
et des hommes sinon ils se coupent de la
réalité j'ai été surpris d'entendre à
votre micro olivier faur que je connais
bien et que j'ai accompagné dans ses
divorces et séparations
j'ai été étonné de ces leçons de morale
il n'en fallait pas plus pour olivier
faure qui a convoqué une conférence de
presse mercredi après-midi afin de
réagir aux propos du ministre de
l'intérieur
il en profite pour appeler le président
de la république à prendre des mesures
concernant christophe castaner ce matin
une ligne rouge a été franchie le fait
pour un ministre de l'intérieur
de chercher à intimider l'un des
dirigeants de l'opposition en ayant
recours à des insinuations relevant de
sa vie privée et d'une atteinte au
fondement même de la démocratie
christophe castaner a commis une faute
grave
dès lors il appartient au président de
la république garant de nos institutions
de convoquer le ministre de l'intérieur
dans les meilleurs délais et d'en tirer
toutes les conséquences je vous remercie
personne une intervention qui n'a pas
laissé christophe castaner insensible le
poussant à réagir par le biais d'une
déclaration à la fp celui-ci a précisé
regretter ces propos
si l'on blessés olivier faure plus tôt
dans la journée de mercredi le ministre
de l'intérieur s'était exprimé sur
twitter cher olivier faure il n'y avait
ni menace ni attaques personnelles dans
mon propos nous nous connaissons depuis
assez longtemps pour savoir l'un et
l'autre que la vie n'est pas linéaire et
nous y avons quelquefois fait face
ensemble
reste désormais à savoir si emmanuel
macron décidera de réagir face à cette
nouvelle polémique provoquée par le
ministre français de l'intérieur et ses
suites de les faire griveaux on en parle
avec denis deux monts pions
éditorialiste politique bonsoir denis
demonpion merci d'être avec nous cette
affaire décidément créé des remous fait
des vagues
est-ce que christophe castaner selon
vous un petit il a exprimé des regrets
entre temps on va dépasser la ligne
rouge et emmanuel macron doite
intervenir et en tirer les conséquences
comme le souhaite olivier faure enfin je
pense que emmanuel macron seraient bien
inspirés de passe peut être cette
affaire mais il est clair que depuis
début de ce qu'on a appelé la sphère
gris jo le ministre de l'intérieur outre
passe ses pouvoirs et sa fonction
pourquoi parce que s'y est d'ailleurs le
déroulement des faits l'ont montré c'est
une affaire qui est devenue judiciaire
il est ministre de l'intérieur on ne
sache pas que le ministre de l'intérieur
est addict et ou au parquet au ministère
de la justice qu'il a à faire et dans ce
dossier il a dès le début dès que
monsieur griveaux benjamin griveaux a
démissionné enfin a renoncé à être
candidat à la mairie de paris
il avait dit il le ministre d'intérieur
dit il faut que la justice soit saisie
que les coupables soient sanctionnés
on ne voit pas à quel titre où il fait
de la basse politique ce qui semble être
le cas quand on observe maintenant les
espèces des changes de cour de
récréation avec olivier faure le premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste
alors ça aussi c'est vrai que ça un peu
agité les médias aujourd'hui
mais il faut ramener ça à sa juste
proportion c'est quoi au fond c'est une
sorte de règlement de compte entre deux
socialistes puisque monsieur castaner
était comme vous le savez membre du
parti socialiste
jusqu'à ce qu'ils fassent défection pour
rejoindre emmanuel macron à l'époque
olivier faur l'avait critiqué pour ça
pour avoir finalement
puis le l'embarcation alors qu'elle
était en train de couler et je pense que
c'était une manière assez peu élégante
du ministre de l'intérieur de lui
renvoyer la monnaie de sa pièce
vous parlez de règlements de comptes on
en a aussi beaucoup parlé dans cette
affaire chacun sur les plateaux de télé
sont allés voilà de leur avis sur les
règlements de comptes peut-être voilà et
des pas et des clés votre vision vous
détestez réaliste politique sur ce
traitement médiatique de cette affaire
vous avez été étonné à vous écouter il
ya eu un emballement absolument
spectaculaire pourquoi parce que bon il
ya eu cette vidéo qui a été même pas
j'allais dire et stork et benjamin
griveaux puisque c'est lui qui l'envoie
d'abord c'est lui qui l'a réalisé qu'ils
envoient propre à lui de vouloir
s'exhiber comme il l'a fait ensuite que
ça a été diffusée sur les réseaux
sociaux il pouvait s'y attendre
n'est ce pas et ce qui est contraire à
la loi évidemment bien sûr et ici ça
doit être sanctionné salle veut ça le
sera mais dans des proportions assez
quand même minime
non ce qui est quand même assez
surprenant c'est qu'il ait démissionné
aussi rapidement parce que vous savez
bien que le libertinage
en tout cas en france c'est aussi vieux
que la politique
d'ailleurs tous les chefs d'état
ministres etc
quand on pense à jacques chirac à
françois mitterrand qui avait des
doubles et des triples vie etc
c'était salué comme quelque chose de
très mal de très viril
voilà et je parle pas de nicolas sarkozy
et de françois hollande aussi donc on
vous allez vous attirer des ennuis eux
sont encore là non merci
c'est tout ça ce sont des faits
totalement établie et que l'état ait
connu de ce qui est surprenant dans le
cas de benjamin griveaux c'est que tout
d'un coup pour une vidéo comme ça qui
circulent il passe pour la victime et
toute la classe politique
je fais cancer en réalité et je tiens
salle de daim
d'un responsable de la république en
mars que s'est il passé c'est que il
avait réalisé un sondage
quelques jours plus tôt et benjamin
griveaux était en train de dévisser dans
les sondages il était même tombé à 13 %
le vert david belliard était passé
devant lui et la république en marche
craignez que il ne passe sous la barre
des 10%
pourquoi parce que ça aurait été pour
lui et pour tout la macro ni un désastre
politique de voir que le parti au
pouvoir n'arrivent pas à s'implanter
dans une ville comme paris
puisqu'on se souvient que en 2018 avant
la crise des gilet jaune
emmanuel macron c'était à l'époque
engagé et avait dit qu'il s'engagerait
dans la campagne des municipales et le
stanislas guérini quel responsable du
parti avaient même tablé sûr 10 me
d'élus donc en gros vous êtes en train
de vous dire que
cette affaire
le fait de piotr uklanski et non ses
complices on ans à venir encore
puisqu'une enquête est en cours a
finalement d'une certaine façon rendu
service à la macro ni au bon on peut le
lire comme ça en tout cas bien entendu
car au fond comment s'appelle-t-il
griveaux en prétexte de de ce scandale
alors bon la méthode est répréhensible
et tout ça bien sûr mes rivaux prend
prétexte
de la mise sur la place publique de
cette vidéo sexuelle de ce sextape comme
on dit maintenant pour pour jeter
l'épongé
mais concrètement et juridiquement rien
ne l'empêchait de poursuivre la bagarre
au contraire il aurait peut-être même
plus s'attirer des sympathies dans le
public
alors c'est quand même assez paradoxal
de parler de la politique du libertinage
qui est vieux comme la politique sauf
que aujourd'hui il ya peut-être un fait
nouveau dans cet effet c'est que c'est
le citoyen qui d'une certaine manière à
une pouvoir de décider du sort d'un
politique
on savait très bien dans les rédactions
il y avait des photos sur mitterrand qui
n'ont jamais été dévoilées on connaît
les conséquences que ça use
quand paris match a révélé effectivement
des photos sur la vie privée de nicolas
sarkozy aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est pas
ça la grande nouveauté est ce qui peut
choquer finalement tous ces politiques
le monde médiatico-politique que le
citoyen alors on juge ne parle d'eux
s'est pas légal mais en tout cas eu ce
pouvoir et sur le destin d'un paulino
mais bien sûr il ya un phénomène nouveau
ses réseaux sociaux et la déflagration
que ça provoque encore que cette vidéo a
été assez peu vu puisqu'elle a été très
vite retiré ce kia elle a été twitté par
quelques personnalités et c'est ça qui a
provoqué les dégâts mais c'est vrai que
vous avez raison de rappeler c'est que
françois mitterrand a une double vie
bien avant d'entrer à l'elysée
et ce n'est que quand il l'a décidé que
on a eu connaissance de cette double vie
de l'existence de sa fille cachée
mazarine etc etc
et c'est peut-être ça la différence
aujourd'hui bien sûr gérer beaucoup bien
sûr ce qu'avant on avait affaire à des
paparazzi on l'a vu avec françois
hollande quand il s'est fait pincer rue
du cirque où il allait retrouver julie
gayet alors même que le que là la
première dame
et et valérie trierweiler effectivement
ça mais ça a amusé la galerie plus
qu'autre chose vous voyez et c'est vrai
que benjamin griveaux a été commencé
comment dirais-je surpris de la la
déflagration parce que le ce et les
réseaux sociaux c'est par définition
instantané ça peut être très prévu
savent ça passe circuler autant que ça
aurait circulé si la vidéo était restée
en ligne
mais quand même il ya les journalistes
qui l'ont vu et vous savez dans le cas
de françois mitterrand les journalistes
accrédités et qui était mitterrandolâtre
il était au courant de l'existence de
mazarine mais simplement il y avait une
espèce de d'omerta de loi du silence
alors même qu'aujourd'hui on nous dit
attention vie privée vie publique il
faut faire un casque et un avant et un
après l affaire griveaux selon dire
beaucoup tendent à le penser en réalité
benjamin griveaux n'a pas
jusqu'à plus ample informé bon il y là
il a comme comme on dit fait une
connerie en se présentant dans cette
vidéo tel qu'il s'est présenté mais il
n'a pas fait de faute politique de ceux
de ce point de vue là il n'a pas on peut
pas comparer à un françois mitterrand
qui avait une fille cachée et pour
comment dirais-je élevé cette fille
cachée et et çà et là mère de sept
enfants utiliser les fonds de la
république mais c'était un autre cas de
figure donc griveaux c'est finalement
une goutte d'eau dans un océan quoi
c'est et je ne pense pas je ne pense pas
que ça comment dirais-je change lui le
fonctionnement de la vie politique
il est certain que d'autres gens seront
à l'affût pour piéger les politiques
mais c'est aux politiques de faire
attention
merci en tout cas denis demonpion
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france est justement selon un sondage
on va découvrir à l'antenne si on veut
bien me le remettre n'est ce pas ce
sondage voilà sondage municipal paris
2019 on voit aujourd'hui que rachida
dati passe en tête à 25 % à des galgos
23% agnès buzyn qui prend la 3e place
provisoire bien évidemment 17% des
intentions de vote avec une quatrième
place pour david belliard premier donc
sauvage des municipales depuis cette
affaire
grivot et la démission de l'ancien
candidat de la république en marche
merci à vous restez avec nous dans
quelques instants la suite de notre
émission en direct sur rt france on
parlera évidemment
de la réforme des retraites et de la
mise en garde aussi de moscou après les
menaces internes hogan d'une
intervention en syrie puis direction les
états unis ou le nevada accueille ce
soir un débat entre les candidats
démocrates à l'investiture le
milliardaire michael bloomberg est
attendu au tournant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ma vie est divisé en deux parties
je précise toujours c'était avant
l'attentât ou après
[Musique]
je me suis promise que je vivrai ma vie
comme si je vivais 334 vie et que je
ferai de mon mieux
et ma fille qui veut vivre oui fatiha je
veux vivre elle veut vivre
parfois je rêve aussi de beslan des
enfants couverts de sang en train de
pleurer des parents qui cherchent de
l'aide de mieux cet endroit s'appelle la
cité des anges
cet attentat qui a duré du 1er au 3
septembre a coûté la vie à 334 personnes
je demande à chaque enfant de me
pardonner de ne pas avoir réussi à
sauver sur tout le monde
[Musique]
le numérique ça et mais aujourd'hui 4 %
des gaz à effet de serre dans le monde
tous les citoyens qui utilisent par
exemple des ordinateurs polluent la
planète
à chaque fois qu'on a une requête
internet qu'on envoie un email
qu'on l'ait qu'une photo sur instagram
ça a un impact carbone un email envoyé
avec une pièce jointe
c'est l'équivalent d'une ampoule allumée
pendant une heure comme ceci
peu de gens ont conscience que le
numérique pollue pire encore ils pensent
que le numérique est un outil qui
permettrait de réduire la consommation
d'énergie le numérique est en quelque
sorte un pharmaco en pharma concept un
mot grec ancien qui veut dire à être à
la fois remède est poison c'est quelque
chose qu'il faut qu'il faut utiliser
avec
avec sagesse avec mesure c'est ce qui
fera le plus de bien à la planète
en effet l'afghanistan n'est pas un lieu
tranquille ce n'est pas un bon pays
l'afghanistan est un endroit très
dangereux pour quelqu'un de célèbre
[Musique]
abbas est devenu célèbre
avant même de réussir ses amis sur
facebook
ses camarades de classe même des gens
dans la rue et des parents disaient
qu'il ressemblait à bruce lee chaque
fois que quelqu'un appelle bruce si je
suis aux anges abbas-ali se présente
comme bruce lee il imite les actes des
infidèles l'islam dénonce des actes
contre la religion commis par les
musulmans un machin
il doit simplement continuer à
s'entraîner par mac os ou peu importe sa
religion qu'ils soient musulmans ou non
voilà quelqu'un qui ressemble à bruce
lee qui peut réussir
regardez à mémoire vivante cela fera
revenir 1 figure de bruce lee dans le
cinéma et le sport c'est génial pour la
promotion du sport il y a une
problématique de documentation
extrêmement importante de la demande en
eau depuis la révolution verte qui a
conduit à cette autosuffisance
alimentaire de l'inde dans ces zones
climatiques aride il ya quasiment plus
d'eau en surface
on compte maintenant à peu près sur le
pays de l'ordre de 25 millions depuis
qu'on paie ce qui est six fois plus que
la chine
cette image d'une femme qui porte un
pont à eau sur la tête et une image que
l'on voit partout pour les femmes c'est
une charge énorme des petites filles
peuvent pas aller à l'école parce
qu'elles doivent aider à cette tâche par
exemple donc ça accentue des inégalités
85% de l'eau consommée
en inde les par l'agriculture c'est un
des premiers exportateurs de blé de riz
des peas qui consomment énormément d'eau
pourraient être produites à l'échelle
mondiale d'eau virtuelle c'est à dire
l'eau qui est contenu dans les produits
qui sont échangées l'inde est un des
plus gros exportateurs d'eau donc c'est
un paradoxe lensois
lee
semble plus important c'est la descente
de dans le cas contraire les oursons ne
peuvent pas être relâchés dans la nature
combien de centimètres
ça doit être un peu près 7 7 et demi
n'est pas pour l'ours est parti et va
récupérer les eaux sont c'est bon ça
saute et s'est jeté sur moi elle m'a
manqué de quelques centimètres
[Musique]
21h merci nous rejoindre en direct sur
arte france pour cette deuxième heure
d'information tout de suite voici les
titres de l'actualité de ce mercredi en
syrie l'onu mettant en garde contre le
péril est imminent des escalades un
conseil de sécurité s'est tenu ce soir
après qu'ankara à menacer damas d'une
offensive militaire imminente dans la
province d'idlib
la russie s'oppose à une déclaration
réclamant un cessez-le-feu et hausse le
ton vis-à-vis de la turquie aux états
unis premier débat télévisé de la
campagne démocrate ce soir à las vegas
le milliardaire michael bloomberg fait
son entrée dans la cour sera-t-il à la
hauteur pour obtenir l'investiture et
défier le des républicains donald trump
lors de la présidentielle de novembre
lui se présente en tout cas comme le
candidat capable de rassembler au centre
la sphère rivaux et dans son sillage des
propos de christophe castaner sur le
patron du premier secrétaire du ps qui
avait dénoncé la veille la légèreté
incroyable de l'ancien candidat à la
mairie paris nouvelle salve de réactions
de la part de la classe politique
indigné alors la sphère griveaux que dit
elle sur la société française
y aura-t-il un avant et un après est ce
qu'on pense qu'est ce qu'on en pense à
l'étranger ce sera l'objet de notre face
à face ce soir
[Musique]
doit-on craindre une escalade dans le
nord ouest de la syrie la turquie menace
damas d'une opération militaire
imminente sur id libre depuis plusieurs
semaines les mimiques soutenu par ankara
affrontent l'armée de bachar al assad
la tension est montée d'un cran après le
décès de militaires turcs après les
bombardements syrien ces menaces
interviennent alors que la russie allié
damas mène des négociations avec ankara
pour faire baisser les tensions
les discussions vaines pour le président
turc de son côté le kremlin a mis en
garde contre toute opération visant
salle bachar al assad
nous entrons dans les derniers jours
pour le régime qui doit cesser son
offensive à idlib et se retirer aux
frontières de l'accord de sotchi c'est
notre dernière mise en garde
malheureusement ni les discussions
menées dans notre pays et en russie ni
les négociations menées sur le terrain
nous nous ont permis d'obtenir le
résultat que nous voulons c'est le cas
pour le dire d'une manière plus
explicite
une opération à idlib est imminente nos
amis turcs n'ont pas réussi à séparer
les militants qui leur sont so mix des
terroristes dans le délai mentionné par
le mémorandum de septembre 2018
ils n'ont pas réussi à le faire un an
plus tard dans le même temps des
provocations depuis la zone dite libre
ont toujours lieu ainsi que des
bombardements visant les positions des
forces armées syriennes
des sites civils et la base aérienne
russe de facebook
naturellement les forces armées
syriennes
tout en réitérant leur attachement à
l'accord initial qui compris l'accord de
cessez-le-feu répondre à ces
provocations inacceptables et nous les
soutenons
l'émissaire de l'onu pour la syrie met
en garde aujourd'hui dont conseil de
sécurité de l'onu contre un péril
imminent des escalades dans le nord
ouest de la syrie
je ne peux rapporté aucun progrès pour
mettre fin aux violences dans le nord
ouest ou relancer le processus politique
aucun accord n'est intervenu entre
moscou et ankara est au contraire les
récentes déclarations suggèrent un péril
en d'escaladé et pour en parler nous
sommes avec à didier destremau ancien
diplomate auteur de le roman de la série
aux éditions du rocher bonsoir billets
destremeau mercier d'être avec nous vous
craignez vous pensez possible également
ce péril imminent d'une escalade
on met en garde le responsable de l'onu
moi je vois que l'ère de gamme et puis
dans l'embarras là la perte de 10 libre
la défaite des des rebelles est
d'étudier disent qu'ils sont se
concentraient les dribbles et ceux des
fêtes de de la turquie a dit visiblement
mais a d'un côté je crois pas clair de
gamme soit capable de désobéir à poutine
il a trop besoin il est très isolé il a
peu trop trop besoin de l'appui de la
russie
il est en mal avec la france tout le
monde le sait il est à couteaux tirés
avec les états unis
pourtant qui sont dans le temps avec lui
et donc il est tout seul je ne crois pas
qu'il qu'il irait au pirée qu'il
attaquerait directement avec ces soldats
turcs avec les supplétifs syrien qui
dépendent de lui peut-être comme il fait
olivier maintenant mais directement avec
les régler avec l'armée turque je crois
pas mais alors quel est l'intérêt de ces
menaces
pour ankara les menaces parce que
d'abord c'est le style de d'erdogan
il me laisse tout le monde il a menacé
macron ya pas très longtemps
il mêle instruments de la menace est
remplacée mais aussi c'est peut-être
c'est peut-être la marque d'une certaine
panique il s'enquit père ils sont que
son investissement en envahissant le
nord de la syrie en appuyant les les
rebelles et la est en fête
les djihadistes comme l'a fait pendant
des années en sueur et est en train est
tenu et une politique et une stratégie
qui était en train de perdre donc
peut-être qui s'affolent et qu'il est
excessif
un coup de son affolement l or moscou en
tout cas met en garde
ankara concrètement qu'est ce que ça
peut donner ankara va se taire obéir
moscou qu'elle peut être justement la
position vous le dit un peu un peu
fébrile delà de la turquie un peu
difficile
c'est difficile de de prévoir mais je
crois que pour l'instant
erdogan est dans l'embarras il hausse le
ton
mais je crois je répète une fois encore
qu'il n'osera pas passer à l'action
c'est trop grave vous avez de la série
devez vous avez de delà de la russie
pardon je crois pas car dogan soit assez
musclée pour se poser de francs parce
que veut poutine c'est à dire 1
c'est-à-dire l'éradication de la poche
d'idlib et la victoire finale de son
poulain bachar el-assad
alors il ya eu un conseil de sécurité de
l'onu aujourd'hui sur ce sujet la russie
s'est opposée à l'adoption par le
conseil de sécurité d'une déclaration
réclamant une cessation des hostilités
le respect du droit international
humanitaire proposée d'ailleurs par la
france
quelle est la stratégie russe pourquoi
ce refus
moi je crois que d'abord les rues sont
très contents de voir la turquie membre
éminent de l'otan quitté un petit peu
c'est un mouvement se otanienne donc
c'est diviser l'ouest divisé l'occident
ça donc c'est une tactique tout à fait
compréhensible de la part de poutine
de l'autre côté la victoire de bachar
el-assad et le calme
la stabilité est revenue en syrie plus
de menaces du côté des lib plus de
djihadistes qui peut faire le va et
vient entre la syrie et la turquie
ça sert des intérêts de dolan de la
russie qui souhaite maintenant calmer le
jeu et que ses relations avec la syrie
et avec le vent général devait de
relations apaisées
normal la russie peut être rester
justement larbitre de la situation la
marge de manoeuvre est encore assez
élevé pour moscou à mon avis la russie
l'est déjà depuis longtemps
larbitre 1 la russie s'est implantée au
levant à achat c'est pratiquement tous
les autres ne parlons pas de la france
on n'y est plus les états unis dépensent
qu'une chaussée à s'en tirer et donc la
russie est seulement de ce bal l arbitre
mais la maîtrise du jeu aujourd'hui la
réunion la région d'idlib et quand même
au coeur des tensions avec ankara est ce
que je reviens de ma première question
est ce que il ya une crainte quand même
que se complique élargissent la
difficulté vous vous mettez le doigt
dessus c'est que erdogan ne veut pas
perdre la face donc il sera obligé
d'assumer
certaines actions pour dire qu'ils se
replient ou que il a laissé libre tomber
volontairement que c'est sa décision que
son choix
donc il veut il a raillé les utilise en
difficulté il n'y a pas de doute mais
une fois encore je crois pas qu'on en
vienne aux mains entre l'armée série
d'un côté et la métrique de l'autre et
aussi le sort des réfugiés très nombreux
900000 on peut comprendre que la turquie
puisse être plus qu'embarrassé par ce
sujet
oui et non je crois que l'afflux de
réfugiés passés et actuels en turquie
est à une carte à tous dans les mains de
deux heures de garde à vue gav peut nous
faire chanter nous les européens en
disant si vous si vous ne nous appuyer
passé vous trouvez pas de solution si
vous n'agissez pas auprès de bachar
el-assad
je vais vous faire envahir par les
réfugiés donc en définitive c'est une
carte qui peut jouer en faveur d'air de
garde mais il est vrai que déjà en
russie en turquie environ trois millions
de réfugiés syriens c'est beaucoup et
encore en rajouter un million ça serait
peut-être excessif et à supportable pour
la population turque
on a parlé du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu qui s'est tenue ce soir est ce
qu'il y a clairement un rôle que peut
jouer l'onu la communauté internationale
dans ce dossier ça sera ma dernière
question à partir du moment où que cette
sécurité
il ya cinq pays qui ont droit de veto
dont la russie et la chine qui
s'opposeront bien évidemment un toute
initiative occidental
tu crois que le conseil de sécurité peut
juste discuter faire du bla bla bla mais
ne pas adopter deux résolutions qui
s'imposerait ni la turquie bien sûr
erdogan s'en fiche complètement
mia la russie merci beaucoup didier
extrêmement aux anciens diplomates
auteur du roman de la syrie aux éditions
du rocher d'avoir été avec nous aux
états unis à présent le milliardaire
michael bloomberg fera son entrée en
piste soir face à ses rivaux démocrates
pour l'investiture à la présidentielle
premier débat télévisé pour celui qui se
présente comme le candidat capable de
rassembler au centre vautours sur son
ascension fulgurante
clément hospital les analystes
politiques ne lui donnait aucune chance
pourtant trois mois plus tard michael
bloomberg en course à l'investiture
démocrate à bondy en troisième position
des sondages et on tombe bien défier
donald trump
je me présente pour vaincre donald trump
j'avais averti dans mon discours à la
convention démocrate en 2016 à
philadelphie que deux mâles trucks
n'était pas apte à occuper cette
fonction
et il est bien pire que ce que j'avais
imaginé pour rattraper son retard
l'ancien maire de new york a dépensé
sans compter plus de 400 millions de
dollars dans une campagne publicitaire
devenu presque omniprésente dans le pays
de quoi inquiéter ses concurrents alors
qu'il talonne les favoris démocrate joe
biden et bernie sanders ses adversaires
ou double leurs attaques
il accuse ainsi le septuagénaire de
chercher à acheter la présidentielle est
dénoncée choix politiques parfois très
conservateur monsieur bloomberg
vous n'allez certainement pas gagner
lorsqu'on sait qu'à new york vous avez
mené une politique raciste
quelques le stopper le risque
krause qui oblige les communautés
minoritaires les afro américains et
latino américain à vivre dans la peur et
l'humiliation dans la ville de new york
vous n'allez pas gagner l'élection
si vous opposé à l'augmentation du
salaire minimum vous savez les gens qui
ont des milliards de dollars ne devrait
pas s'opposer une augmentation du
salaire minimum au dessus de 7 $ 25 de
leur île charge de sanders alors que le
milliardaire n'a cessé d'osciller entre
les familles démocrate et républicaine
au gré de ses ambitions politiques
michael bloomberg est poursuivi par sa
politique de contrôles policiers
systématiques ne stoppe en frisk
décision qu'il a déploré deux semaines
avant de se lancer dans la course à la
présidentielle
ils viennent approche que je regrette
profondément la vue d'une pratique
policière appelée stop and fisc gelé
défendu pendant trop longtemps car je ne
comprenais pas alors la douleur à
justifier qu'elles causaient aux jeunes
familles noires et métisses ainsi qu'à
leurs enfants
j'aurais dû agir plus tôt et plus
rapidement pour y mettre fin
je n'ai pas fait et je me suis excusé
alors que michael bloomberg entend
rassembler l'électorat démocrate modérée
la course à l'investiture semble encore
très ouverte
le médiateur va participer aujourd'hui à
son premier débat dans le nevada état où
sera organisé samedi le troisième vote
pour la primaire
l'afghanistan face à une impasse
politique selon les résultats définitifs
de la commission électorale indépendante
le président sortant achraf
rania obtenu un peu plus de 50% des voix
il est donc réélu à la tête du pays mais
son adversaire historique abdullah
abdullah ne l'entend pas de cette
oreille et signe que la commission
électorale n'a aucune légitimité
ashraf ghani lui compte s'appuyer sur sa
victoire pour relancer les négociations
avec les talibans ce n'est pas seulement
une victoire lors d'une élection c'est
aussi la victoire de la république
islamique d'afghanistan
avec courage et stratégie nous ferons
avancer les négociations de paix mais ce
sera la nation afghane qui prendra la
décision finale
il n'y aura pas de décision cachée à ce
sujet les chiffres annoncés aujourd'hui
sont ceux d'une fraude électorale d'un
coup d'état contre la démocratie d'une
trahison de la volonté du peuple et de
le considérons comme illégal depuis sa
fondation sur la base de votre propre et
biométriques
le parti de la stabilité et de la
convergence et le gagnant de cette
élection et nous annonçons notre
victoire ait deux candidats qui
revendiquent donc la victoire une crise
politique qui se dessine alors que
pensent les avenants de cette élection
présidentielle quel bilan d'ashraf ghani
éléments de réponse l' annonce des
résultats donnent un nouveau message au
peuple
il est destiné à ceux qui ont dirigé le
peuple pendant 40 ans et imposé la
guerre civile j'ai l'espoir que notre
pays se dirige progressivement vers la
paix tout le monde a attendu pendant
cinq mois
l'activité économique s'est arrêtée en
raison des élections maintenant que les
résultats de l'élection sont annoncés
nous aspirons la paix plus que les
résultats de l'élection
mon opinion est que ashraf ghani a
fourni des services publics a fait du
très bon travail a construit des
infrastructures
aux puciers au président est réélue cela
montre qu'il a fait du très bon travail
et que le peuple est satisfait et donc
une nouvelle on écoute maintenant
l'analyse de david rigoulet roze
chercheur à l'iris et ellipses un des
griefs justement du président sera fera
ni c'est d'avoir été jusqu'à présent un
peu laissé à la marge des négociations
directes entre les talibans et les
américains le processus de ces
négociations s'est poursuivie d'une
certaine manière sans la balle et
parfois même sur les consultations en
tout cas pas a priori du gouvernement
afghan
il n'en reste pas moins que les
américains ont besoin quand même d'un
gouvernement qui soit susceptible de
négocier après dans le cadre d'un
dialogue entre afghans puisque dans les
négociations de doha ont été prévus
trois étapes en fait la première étant
cessez le feu qui serait une mesure de
confiance demandé par les américains sur
une semaine et à l'issue de ce de cette
mesure de confiance si le cessez le feu
était effectif il y aurait la
possibilité effectivement d'aller
signature d'un accord dont les
paramètres ont été déjà assez largement
des établis entre les deux parties avec
une troisième étape justement qu'ils
poseraient la question du droit du
dialogue intra afghan qui est une
nécessité pour aboutir et finaliser ce
processus et c'est là où on retrouve
effectivement la crise actuelle je vous
en parlais il ya quelques instants aux
états unis le milliardaire michael
bloomberg qui fait donc son entrée en
piste ce soir premier débat télévisé
pour lui pour faire face donc à ses
rivaux démocrates pour tenter d'obtenir
l'investiture du parti pour aller
affronter donald trump lent de la
prochaine présidentielle
pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis chattanooga aux états unis avec
anthony brian logan blogueur politique
c'est notre rubrique
vu de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir anthony et brian logan merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
avoir déjà pour bien qu'on comprenne
depuis paris quel est l'enjeu ce soir de
ce débat qui va se dérouler dans le
nevada à las vegas à ce qu'il va être
très suivi est ce que c'est un débat
très attendu
c'est ce qui est en jeu lors de ce débat
c'est le cas du parti démocratique non
pas simplement donné 20 mais également
dans les années à venir qu'il fallait
choisir entre un parti socialiste que la
présente bernie sanders ou à un parti
plus modérée avec des jeux se tourner
dans le monde j'étais donc il faut voir
qu'il ya une chance de trouver partie
cela sera très intéressant c'est que je
pense que cela va déterminer l'avenir du
parti alors mais quelle bloomberg on le
disait qui fait ses premiers pas ce soir
qui entrent dans cette course est ce
qu'il peut créer selon vous la surprise
qu'est ce qu'on dit de nuit justement
aux états unis notamment chez les
démocrates
sinon elle pourrait créer la surprise
parce que il au numéro deux dans les
sondages au niveau national est aussi
doué très loin quand les gens disent que
c'est parce que la d'argent mais
beaucoup de personnes ont de l'argent et
pourtant il n'ya pas à ce niveau passait
d'un sur deux bassins notamment
s'agissant de contrôle au faciès ainsi
que ce qu'il a dit par le passé mais je
pense qu'ils pourraient quand on met
tout cela grâce à son palmarès un an
l'urgent est grâce à ses dépenses cela
permettra également de savoir à quel
point les démocrates vont se séparer de
michael huber pour aller faire une
gauche plus radicale d'ajustement
c'était ma prochaine question est-ce que
selon vous mais quelle bloomberg est
assez à gauche justement pour les
démocrates on le présente toujours comme
un milliardaire il est accusé notamment
par son rival bernie sanders d'acheter
un petit peu sa réputation cette
campagne c'est difficile à dire parce
que si on étudie tout le spectre
politique du monde déjà de washington il
est assez à gauche et il va encore
pouvoir faire bernie sanders est qu'ils
veulent qu'il est dans cette direction
me tourner les américains anormaux ou le
pourrait être assez à gauche je ne veux
pas aller trop à gauche parce que des
missions de ce type de couches chose
mais c'est un candidat très spécifiques
et je ne sais pas chez beaucoup de
personnes vont voter pour lui lors des
élections non des primaires il a de bons
résultats parce que les extrémistes vote
mais en novembre ils pourraient avoir
moins de succès magna pourrait avoir de
meilleurs résultats
c'est ainsi le reçoit l'investiture du
parti démocrate mais c'est difficile à
savoir dès à présent qu'est ce qui vous
fait dire justement que michael
bloomberg pourrait avoir de meilleurs
résultats vous parliez de la spécificité
entre un candidat plus spécifiques vous
avez dit bernie sanders en quoi est il
spécifique et qu'elles peuvent être
justement ces faiblesses ans que michael
bloomberg n'aurait pas selon vous pour
affronter donald trump center c'est un
candidat de la spécificité parce que
c'est un socialiste démocrate et pour
les américains c'est un mot tabou ils ne
veulent pas de ce chapitre ils ne
veulent pas de communisme en règle
générale
mais soit on centre gauche soit
centre-droit s'il n'y a pas vraiment
extrême aux états unis donc il ne va
plaire aux personnes qui sont vraiment
très à gauche mais la majorité des
américains n'y sont pas et la majorité
des américains
ils ne sont pas trop à gauche que ce
niveau démocrate un général michael
bloomberg pourrait plaire plus au centre
s'il réussissait à se mettre sur le
devant de la scène mais il faudrait être
considérée comme raciste
en tout cas il n'est pas extrémiste
comme bernie sanders qu'en est il des
autres candidats il ya aussi la bête
warren joe biden qui a beaucoup chuté
sur les sondages le jeune beauté geele
dont on a beaucoup parlé est ce qu ils
ont quand même encore en leur chance à
l'heure qu'il est selon vous ils n'ont
aucune chance
isabelle s'en sortait très bien au début
de la course
mais effectivement m est tombé dans les
sondages elle a admis qu'elle est
sentais très mal sorti lors du dernier
débat c'est la débrouille bien des
problèmes au niveau des élections
nationales pour les autres candidats
cela se passe également mal c'est le sol
depuis de l'outil tchèque je ne pense
pas que les américains soient prêts à
élire un président lgbt ne s'agit pas
tous mes phobies
mais les gens sont très religieux
ils ne sont pas vraiment prêts à en
faire ce choix donc je ne pense pas
qu'il a sa chance l'humain ce soit ben
saunders qui perdrait contre donald
trump ou michael bournival qui pourrait
être un candidat très solide s'ils le
recevaient d'investiture merci beaucoup
anthony à brienne l'organe d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france
touristes étudiants main d'oeuvre dès
demain plus aucun ressortissant chinois
ne pourra entrer en russie des mesures
sanitaires prises contre le nouveau
coronavirus les précisions ni l'anafé
radiant la russie ferme ses portes aux
chinois ce décret vise à empêcher sur le
territoire russe
propagation du nouveau coronavirus aussi
appelé kovy 19
selon cette mesure temporaire il sera
seulement permis aux chinois de
transiter via la russie
concrètement ils pourront faire une
simple escale vers ou à partir de
l'europe
une décision motivée par de nouveaux
chiffres annoncés par pékin hoyé
actuellement 57 1805 cas diagnostiqués
dont 11 1977 cas sévères il ya un total
de quatorze 1376 qu'à soigner est sorti
de l'hôpital il y à un total de 2004 cas
de mort à cause du virus
si officiellement il n'y a plus aucun
malades touchés par le virus en russie
moscou reste néanmoins très préoccupés
par la menace sanitaire
il y a quelques jours déjà les liaisons
ferroviaires avaient été coupés et le
nombre de vols vers des villes chinoises
restreint des mesures radicales qui ont
provoqué de lourdes conséquences sur le
plan économique
l'industrie du voyage est ainsi
fortement impactée en russie car le
marché chinois reste un des premiers
vivier du tourisme en 2019 2,3 millions
de citoyens chinois sont ainsi entrés en
russie dont 1,5 million de touristes et
plus de 320 milles pour des voyages
d'affaires
les groupes constitués environ 80 % du
flux touristiques en provenance de chine
autrement dit le flux s'était asséchée
et désormais il est figé
bien sûr les pertes sont colossales mais
elles concernent avant tout les
entrepreneurs chinois
au delà du secteur touristique la russie
risquent aussi de souffrir d'un problème
de main d'oeuvre
car les chinois sont notamment très
présent dans les grands projets de
construction et l'importation de
produits de consommation
mais la mesure est provisoire dans le
reste du monde
la propagation du virus semble toujours
sous contrôle
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
à notre débat sur la sphère griveaux qui
n'en finit pas de faire réagir cette
affaire que dit elle sur la société
française y aura-t-il un avant et un
après caisse
on en pense à l'étranger nous en
débattrons avec nos invités
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
alors ce coup ci c'est interdit
d'interdire
[Musique]
ce qui s'est passé sur tesla si vous
voulez est assez symptomatique du reste
vous avez une déconnexion complète entre
la valeur et le prix si vous prenez la
valorisation boursière c'est à dire on
est monté jusqu'à 165 milliards pour une
boîte qui depuis le début père en cumulé
6 milliards et demi je ne validerai pas
la valorisation actuelle qui est
complètement décorrélé des fondamentaux
en effet mais après il y a tout de même
les aspects dans cette société qui
peuvent être valorisés à une certaine
dans certains montants au delà en tout
cas de deux des voitures en elle même il
y à la technologie du logiciel qui est à
l'intérieur et il ya également les
batteries qui peuvent être vendus ou la
technologie qui peuvent être vendus à
d'autres personnes ils vont 350 mille
voitures
ça veut dire que vous valoriser la
voiture entre 400 et 500 mille dollars
la voiture c'est une manipulation de
cours pur et dur
loïc et geoffroy de la tulle et sont
deux frères explorateurs animés par une
passion commune l'eau
[Musique]
pour leur cinquième expédition ils ont
choisi de sillonner l'amérique du sud en
side-car à la rencontre des populations
locales
en cinq mois de la vie de sao paulo a
soif et à la terre de feu inhabitée ils
ont parcouru plus de 14 mille kilomètres
motivés par cette question
naître usages de l'eau témoins utiles de
notre lien la nature
et
[Musique]
à l'atterrissage quelque chose a cassé
le train d'atterrissage ouais c'est
compliqué l'aérodrome et glacé les gars
ça commence à m'énerver
là bas tu voi au regard notamment pas
fait attention
et quelle est la profondeur sans tombe
des 4000 m
nestor j'espère qu'ils vont obtenir des
données uniques sur le champ magnétique
ça c'est le toit du monde cela veut dire
que tout est possible
les gens ici m'ont fortement étonné
c'est collectif c'est une véritable
équipe dont les membres sont prêts à
travailler sans broncher pour l'idée ses
nerfs pour à vue de nez que tout se
passe comme prévu
[Musique]
soyez les bienvenus
21h30 en direct sur rt france merci de
nous rejoindre
la sphère griveaux et dans son sillage
les propos de christophe castaner sur le
patron du premier secrétaire du ps qui
avait dénoncé la veille la légèreté
incroyable à de l'ancien candidat à la
mairie de paris
nouvelle salle de réaction de la part de
la classe politique indigne et une
nouvelle fois la sphère griveaux que dit
elle sur la société française y
aura-t-il un avant et un après comment
surtout l'aperçoit ton à l'étranger
c'est l'objet de notre face à face ce
soir
[Musique]
et pour en débattre nous sommes sur ce
plateau avec roanne rosé dorado
journaliste espagnole correspondant à
paris bon soir roanne rosé dorado merci
d'être avec nous en direct par skype
matteo gisèle berti rédacteur en chef de
putsch italien on le précise
bonsoir météo gesell berti merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france juan
rosé dorado la première question est
pour vous comment avez vous perçu vous
cette affaire grivot en tant que
espagnol en tant qu'étranger
correspondant à paris
salut vous étonner un petit peu oui
surpris tout à fait parce
qu'effectivement s'attendait pas à
révélations dé ces vidéos de monsieur
gérin à grimaud est d'autant plus que
nous les espagnols s'intéresse beaucoup
à la politique française et notamment à
ces élections municipales et notamment à
paris puisque la maire sortante madame
anne hidalgo et est né en espagne et de
ses relations avec l'express où
d'importantes on connait vraiment des
suiveurs de l'actualité de la politique
municipale à paris les élections qui
s'annoncent au mois au mois de mars
on était vraiment vraiment surpris
encore une fois on s'attendait pas qu'on
personne puisqu'il n'y avait pas eu des
rumeurs souvent les journalistes on a
des rumeurs des commentaires quelques
jours auparavant qui vous disent qu'il
ya quelque chose qui va se passer
c'était pas vraiment le cas pour nous
cette fois ci donc encore une fois la
surprise mais bien sûr on s'est beaucoup
intéressée et on a beaucoup travaillé
sur ce qui s'est passé les premiers
jours avec le renoncement à être
candidat à la mairie de paris mais aussi
sur les conséquences des ce renoncement
par rapport à monsieur nouveau mais
aussi par rapport à la république en
marche et même à monsieur mc ren et puis
bien sûr aussi on s'est intéressé aux
protagonistes de cette affaire puisque
parmi les protagonistes de cette affaire
il ya un particulièrement qui est né en
espagne d'origine espagnole monsieur
juan branco donc il y avait beaucoup des
récents qui faisait que nous les
espagnols les journalistes espagnols
correspondant à paris étions intéressés
ont ce qui s'est passé depuis une petite
semaine
alors on va aller plus en détail un dans
la réaction notamment des espagnols on
va tourner vers matteo gisèle berti
l'italien s'est pas très loin de
l'espagne où aussi matteo surpris par
cette affaire griveaux et cette
démission est sans doute tout a été très
rapide
je dois dire que j'aurais cru que
l'ancien candidat à la mairie de paris
recule restait encore un petit peu on
dire dans l'allée mais effectivement
tout est très grave
en italie la chose tirer l'attention de
médias mais qu'ils ont ils y sont tout
simplement subi ce qui s'est dit dans
les médias français
ils ont suivi aussi l'évolution du point
de vue juridique judiciaire surtout de
la situation mais vous n'êtes pas trop
étonné parce que on n'a pas eu vraiment
des mecs des situations similaires dans
le sens d'un candidat qui est obligé à
démissionner ou en tout cas ça reste une
course dans les dernières journées mais
sans doute dans la politique italienne
on est aussi d'autres autre situation
oui effectivement vous évoquez
certainement la situation de silvio
berlusconi
évidemment on va en parler parce que la
question évidemment que tout le monde se
pose c'est la même chose en espagne est
ce que le même candidat est ce qu'il
démissionne il reste au pouvoir
les espagnols se disent m'ont pas écouté
c'est pas grave c'est sa vie privée et
le candidat reste où justement ça aurait
été certainement la même situation
alors on n'a pas eu la même situation
dont c'est difficile de dire mais par
contre non mais on connaît la mentalité
oui mais
mais on a eu un cas assez semblable à
c'était en 2012 au in conseillère
municipale de la ville d'in ville de
près de tolède avait envoyé une vidéo
érotique à un de ses copains copains qui
a publié cette vidéo
la première réaction de cet élu a été de
le dénoncer bien sûr mais aussi des
démissionné en tant qu'élu municipal de
sa ville de sa bile donc la réaction
première était dé démissionner mais à
l'époque je vous le rappelle c'était en
c'est quand même assez assez loin la loi
n'interdisait pas neuneu n'interdisait
pas la diffusion des vidéos de cette
caractéristique des tout simplement
parce que la loi espagnole avait pas
considérer que si vous en voyez il ne
vivait cette vidéo et publiée par la
personne qui l'a reçu volontairement de
votre part il n'y avait pas de peine à
appliquer des puits est ce qu'ils
essaient d'affaires évidemment différent
enfreint la loi espagnole a changé est
devenu comme la loi française c'est à
dire que maintenant il faut donc avoir
l'autorisation de la personne qui a
envoyé la vidéo pourquoi la premier donc
à votre réponse a priori ça se serait
passé de la même façon parce que dans
d'autres dont d'autres cas où des élus
ont commis peut-être par des fautes
pénales mais d'aider son père par
rapport à ce projet à son attitude vers
la population ou à certaines axes de sa
politique
on se sont vus rapidement vu m des côtes
et ce n'est pas une faute
ces débats
les dans les normales on est on est dans
la morale donc par contre effectivement
du côté espagnol
en termes beaucoup à l'exemplarité entre
guillemets donc si effectivement vous
êtes entre guillemets toujours coupable
de quelque chose de amoral il est
probable que vous soyez obligé de
démissionner tout simplement parce que
vous n'irez pas très loin et puis on
savait dès 60 dans le cas de monsieur
rivaux que malheureusement pour lui ils
ont que les enquêtes d'opinion ne lui
était pas favorable non plus pour
pouvoir continuer à être candidat rim
était aussi alberti parce que c'est vrai
que il ya la décision en propre et
personnels de benjamin griveaux mais il
ya aussi l'opinion publique qui
finalement on a allumé toutes les
chaînes de télé lui toute la presse
alors ça ne reflète pas forcément
nécessairement toujours l'opinion des
français on la connaît pas
nécessairement sur ce point mais qui a
quand même largement défendu benjamin
griveaux en disant que c'était
effectivement là lui la victime c'est au
lieu de la loi elle est effectivement
vous avez réagi comment vous en italie
par rapport à ça effectivement disons
que c'était plutôt une réussite comme
celle des français pensent que la
victime était effectivement benjamin
gris bordeaux mais quand un sens à cette
vidéo a été publiée avec le passé le
passage du temps on a vu que qu'il y
avait aussi des situations un peu plus
complexe à définir ce qui est
intéressant c'est en tout cas le fait
que comme disaient nos ados avec des
puits 2012 depuis une dizaine d'années
la situation a changé vraiment un peu
dans tous les pays européens en ce qui
concerne le
les crimes qui sont liées à la
discussion de vidéos non seulement à
caractère pornographique merci qui ont
comme protagoniste de jeunes par exemple
le à l'école d'un des cadres des cyber
cyber harcèlement et loire ont changé
beaucoup en italie il ya eu un cas qui
n'a pas conservé un homme ou une femme
politique mais une fille et qui a été
effectivement victime et qui est un peu
le même cas de 2,2
benjamin guégot mais cette chose a
permis de devancer un petit peu surtout
du point de vue technique aussi parce
que t'es pas d'accord c'est compliqué
c'est pas facile et c'est encore
compliqué de enlever des contenus
d'internet de contenu des vidéos de ce
type qui porte atteinte à la dignité
d'une personne
nous on a eu du mal à vous avez parlé
des la victime c'est vrai il est la
victime parce que la loi dit qu'il est
et il est victime et en espagne on a eu
du mal aussi à défendre le fait qu'il
soit la victime dont les sources qu'il
n'y aurait pas eu des cas griveaux s'il
n'y avait pas eu des vidéos personnes
lui avaient débordé des registres ce
type de vidéos et de l'envoyer sachant
le risque que ça peut nous poser pour un
homme politique donc un homme public qui
en plus à l'époque il était ministre il
était même pas candidat n'ait pas été
ministre que c'est encore plus plus plus
plus plus compliqué et puis il faut pas
non plus oublier que la france paraît
quelques découvre la sphère griveaux
mais on oublie qu'il y a quelques années
il ya eu quelque chose de semblable
honfleur en france c'était le cas
valbuena avec karim benzema une vidéo
aussi sexuel qui a été publié
et qui a eu des gants même dans le
procès n'a pas encore vraiment terminée
eu lieu en fait qui va avoir lieu
donc ce n'est pas la première fois que
ça arrive et et nous on a été surpris
des devoirs comme en france on prenait
ça comme si c'était la première fois bah
non non c'est pas la première fois
c'est déjà arrivé et encore une fois ce
qu'on veut en espagne en a cette
sensation c'est qu'on est très
moralisateur on fronce quand on parle
vers les publics mais on n'est pas du
tout quand on porte un regard sur sa vie
sur sa vie privée
la vie privée et la vie publique c'est
vrai qu'il ya une ligne qui est des plus
en plus minces mais en même temps
c'était aussi on considère que les
hommes politiques ont aussi quelque
chose à faire là dessus c'est à dire on
ne peut pas aller sur les plateaux de
télé ou de radio pour parler décès sans
fonder sa famille on peut pas aller sur
les couvertures d'aider la presse people
et puis demander qu'on ne s'intéresse
pas à votre vie privée que vous-même
avait étalé donc il ya quelques années
la france fait c'est très bien la
différence
mais dès qu'une quinzaine d'années en
france on fait plus vraiment cette
différence et c'est surtout les hommes
politiques qu'il a qui la font pas donc
faut faire très attention et c'est pour
ça qu'on a parfois du mal à considérer
que tu es dans des cas comme ça les
personnes ces personnes dont les cas de
béja langue de veau sont vraiment les
premières victimes
météo chez elle berti vous n'êtes pas
d'accord justement c'est peut-être vous
parliez de silvio berlusconi fait vous
êtes habitués mois de problèmes mais pas
s'occuper des moeurs bien que c'est une
attitude est enceinte
on a eu aussi
toute politique qui ont étalé leur vie
familiale
l'italie a été longtemps un peu moins
mais elle a été longtemps un pays très
catholique donc les hommes et femmes
politiques ont souvent présenté leur
modèle familial comme un modèle de la
famille parfaite mais il y avait tout un
tas de problèmes derrière mais est en
revanche ce qui a changé beaucoup en
italie notamment depuis l'arrivée au
pouvoir mais aussi dans les parlements
quand il est l opposition du mouvement 5
étoiles et qui a imposé une feuille de
route aux institutions italiennes pour
que on observe le comportement vis-à-vis
des institutions et donc aussi des
citoyens très qu'on dirait modèle
effectivement vous souvenez il
l'année passée l'un des secrétaires
d'état qui était un représentant de la
ligue 2 matin 5 min bien qu il que ça
finit était encore au gouvernement il a
dû démissionner pour une faute de la
part de cette personne de ceux
responsables politiques et aux yeux de
la loi
benjamin griveaux les fautifs de rien on
est dans la pure au mans voilà justement
la chose par contre que qui est très
intéressant dans ce cas était jugé par
quelqu'un qui finalement a estimé que
comme il faut pas
va payer cet été mais alors que
effectivement il avait commis aucun
crime
voilà c'était des ressorts de la vie
effectivement von rosen dorado matteo
j'ai des vertiges qui fait référence à
l'activiste russe piotr pawlenty qui
aujourd'hui se plaignait un voilà c'est
une situation monstrueuse parce que je
pensais que la france était le pays de
la liberté d'expression est un peu vexé
qu'on enlève sa vidéo du site et voilà
il revient sur cette rhétorique benjamin
griveaux qui a utilisé sa famille en se
présentant comme une icône
quelle a été la réaction des espagnols
par rapport justement cet argument qu
avance cet activiste russe opposant
d'ailleurs à poutine
déjà la première des choses c'est que ce
qu'on a bien compris si vous voulez
c'est que l'argument will où il a dit
c'est pour dénoncer l' hypocrisie ça on
a tous bien compris effectivement il ya
une certaine forme et un écho chez voilà
il ya une forme d' hypocrisie puisque la
vie politique qui ce soir l'espagne que
ce soit en france que ce soit honni des
limons collex bien comment ça se passe
en italie
les politiques sont tombés dans les
progrès si depuis des décennies
d'années est donc cet argument là on
peut bien le comprend le comprendre donc
on peut c'est pour ça qu'on a du mal à
trouver vite sur la démocratie tout même
si on commence à balancer en pâture la
vie privée des gens c'est déjà un vrai
sujet c'est un vrai sujet mais déjà il
ya la loi
quand je vous ai dit d'espagne a dû
changer la loi parce qu'à l'époque en
2012 elle permettait ce type de
défenseur et le
l'artiste russe n'aurait jamais été et
molestés et en espagne c'est à ce moment
là c'est pour ça qu'on a dû changer et
la loi mais au même taux encore une fois
attention
la faute n'est pas aux réseaux sociaux
la faute n'est pas à la population à
c'est lui qui a trouvé au qui a eu la la
vidéo qui a décidé de la publier parce
que si on fait si on commençait comme ça
il n'y aurait jamais des deux lanceurs
d'alert on a oublié un moment donné
qu'il ya eu aussi des rangs third alerte
ce n'est pas la même qu'à mais ne
mettons pas des barrières à droite et à
gauche pour essayer de vraiment cantonné
ça a une histoire de vie privée et vie
publique
oui ça existe mais en même temps la
peopolisation de la vie politique ce
n'est pas nous les journalistes non plus
qui l'avons créé ccc aussi les
politiques qui sont allés vers elle pour
essayer d'arriver avait osé les aux
électeurs donc ça c'est le risque
faisons très faut faire très attention
faut juste se rappeler que cette vidéo
avait été proposé un certain nombre des
médias est un média notamment qui arrive
qui a refusé de la voir des ddd la date
de la présente et c'est pour ça qu'ils
sont allés aussi sur un site à l'étroit
à l'étranger mais attention cpcc pénale
en france donc c'est bien ce à l'aide en
espagne aussi c'est bien mais en même
temps ne restons pas la faute uniquement
que sur celui qui l'a qui l'a publié
parce que les hommes politiques ont
aussi une part de responsabilité dans
cette dérive à laquelle on assiste
depuis une dizaine d'années alberti
les hommes politiques ont clairement
pour vous aussi une responsabilité dans
cette affaire
je pense que les hommes politiques ont
une attitude un peu celle service
vis-à-vis des médias quand il leur
intéresse les médias ils sont tout
sourire
arrêtez pas de citer les deux interviews
et épées et des échanges avec les médias
commentent et là ils sont entre
guillemets mina cds il les évite
d'ailleurs la chose intéressante c'est
que ben j'ai d'ailleurs autres chaînes
selon lui pas des journalistes en tout
cas mais les agents des organes et donc
ça n'est pas du tout la presse qui a qui
a géré ce cas parce que c'est quelque
chose qui est l'objet de critiques
vis-à-vis de la porte-parole actuel qui
a parlé de presse de bas niveau plus
exactement l'expression mais que c'était
pas la presse d'ailleurs médias
justement comme disait mon confrère a
précisé guy cette vidéo
c'étaient les réseaux sociaux c'était
tout ce qui est comment dire la latitude
de personnes ne peuvent aussi une espèce
de voyeurisme sur internet mais sans
doute il y a encore parlé de
responsabilité de la part des politiques
mais sans doute il ya une attitude qui
différentes mais en même temps je dis
aussi que cette attitude est alimenté
par l'exigence de se mettre un peu un
scènes quotidiennes campagne électorale
quand il y a
un moment d'échangés avec la population
c'est un peu comme si les publics
voulaient voir un aspect humain de la
vie politique même temps libre et rohner
est quand même encore une fois ce mot
qui revient c'est l'hypocrisie ce qu'on
fait ce qui se passe aujourd'hui on
pourrait parler de la double vie de
françois mitterrand quand les français
ont découvert ça ça doublé biya après
ils n'acceptaient pas non plus de ne pas
savoir qu'il avait une double vie on a
assisté au des bords sont directes 2
nicolas sarkozy avec cécilia sarkozy
auront assisté mais les journalistes
savaient mais gardez ce voilà
aujourd'hui ça fait citoyen qui jettent
enclos
c'est différent c'est ça la différence
c'est ça la différence que effectivement
aujourd'hui via le réseau sociaux donc à
nous en tant que journaliste françois
mitterrand les photos et voilà
mais on espère revenir à l'époque on
disait rien à l'époque parce que la
ligne qui différencie la vie privée la
vie publique était beaucoup plus
importante qu'est ce qu'elle est
aujourd'hui et c'est à nous de faire
notre travail et de voir où est
l'information n'est pas donc mais c'est
vrai que maintenant aujourd'hui on doit
compter sur le réseaux sociaux nous on
le fait les politiques doivent doivent
les faire mais nenê sur prêts non pas de
voir ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui parce que
depuis des décennies ça se passe selon
le voyons les voyez venir encore on
voyait les divorces en direct on a vu
des me suicide en direct avec la
campagne à un moment donné de monsieur
de monsieur hollande tout ça ça se passe
maintenant des ventes tout le monde
parce que les réseaux sociaux sont là
cedrico d'ailleurs attendu du
gouvernement n'a
profitez profiter de cette occasion en
tout cas pour suggérer une loi qui va
davantage vers le contrôle d'internet
mateo gil alberti est ce que c'est ça la
solution
non je suis comme complètement en
désaccord avec cette proposition comme
je suis en désaccord avec la loi
plusieurs aspects de la loi qui misent
qui a limité conduire à réduire à
combattre la loi bien sûr il faut
empêcher les eighties mondiale et de
sévir sur internet mais il ya toujours
un risque de limiter la liberté
d'expression déjà on à l'aller les flics
nous c'est très difficile après de faire
notre travail et donc de faire aussi
parfois les naceur d'art est mon alerte
si on a des lois qui continuent à
limiter la la la la la liberté
d'expression en revanche on pouvait par
exemple s'attaquer à des lois et créer
disons belgrade plus tôt qui portait en
otage par exemple les mineurs de façon
encore plus importante parce qu'il faut
pas oublier que toute cette affaire
guilbault il ya malheureusement une
famille qui est qui qui était en dire
sur la scène sans que personne n'avait
rien de la veille et donc je pense que
il y a des marges d'amélioration ou de
changement d'un justement la protection
des mineurs la peste la protection des
personnes plus faibles qui ne peut qu'y
qu'ils pouvaient être exposés sur
internet à des risques qui sont
disproportionnés par rapport à roanne
rosé de radeaux justement aller dans le
sens de plus de protection notamment
pour les personnes les plus fragiles les
mineurs parce que c'est vrai que on
parle beaucoup de benjamin griveaux qui
est un homme
j'irai majeur vacciner on parle
peut-être moins voilà les victimes des
jeunes qui sont souvent justement en
prise avec ses fameuses revenge port
n'est qu' on souffre beaucoup faire
davantage quand même de protection
niveau oui des protections par rapport à
effectivement aux populations de plus
vulnérable donc les les jeunes notamment
par rapport effectivement à ce phénomène
suis tout à fait d'accord avec lui mais
ça ne doit pas non plus aller audelà a
contrôlé la fin de l'anonymat sur
internet ou sur tout ça n'était pas
anonyme
voilà donc ces dames ce qui s'était
passé n'était pas lui mais on a les
politiques au togo ce qu'on doit quelque
chose qu'il n'arrive pas à contrôler ses
affaires une loi pour l'interdire
et donc ça on peut mais on peut pas le
terme et tous les journalistes ont
laissé masqué il ya tout un tas des lois
qui délimite le champ d'investigation
des journalistes on n'a pas le droit de
dire ça on n'a pas le droit de diffuser
ça on n'a pas le droit de donc non il
faut quand même protéger les populations
qu'il faut protéger mais ne généralisons
pas parce que ça n'est pas la société ça
n'aide pas la démocratie ça n'aide que
ceux qui ont quelques sorte quelque
chose à cacher météo sont les albertains
le mot de la fin
non pas contre la liberté d'expression
effectivement mon confrère toute
occasion est bonne pour essayer
d'introduire une nouvelle loi qui
d'ailleurs pu me aussi un sapin type
d'information qui est de toute façon
légitime parce que souvent on peut voir
aussi des amendes très importante pour
les journalistes pour les organes de
presse il faut toujours se rappeler que
les journalistes sont au service de la
communauté
et donc il est ils donnent leur
contribution
merci beaucoup en tout cas tous les deux
rois ne rosé dorado matteo gisèle berti
merci d'avoir été avec nous pour ce
débat merci à vous et restez avec nous
dans quelques instants un point complet
sur l'actualité
[Musique]
daniel parfois on n'a que des
éléphanteaux victimes de braconnage
particulièrement brutale car
malheureusement les bébés sont souvent
témoin non seulement du meurtre de leur
mère mais aussi la voix se faire
massacrer des coupes et nombreux check
[Musique]
out
je crois que les éléphants sourient
c'est ce que je vois chez les petits
leurs expressions faciales change
[Musique]
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs se jouer mais les mecs
ne sont pas toujours respectées les
couleurs changent de camp les pions
prennent la place des rois de films
stratégies peuvent porter des résultats
inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
je suis allée de chômeurs et chaque
semaine dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
[Musique]
à bientôt sur rt france la société
afghane ne permet pas aux femmes d'être
libres comme les hommes les hommes
peuvent faire ce qu'ils veulent mais pas
les femmes
[Musique]
nous avons encore besoin d'un garçon en
tout cas j'ai sept filles et pas de fils
[Musique]
en fait seuls les pies qui viennent chez
nous et qui joue avec elles savent que
c'est une fille dehors quand elle joue
avec une balle
personne ne s'en rend compte que c'est
une fille et tout le monde croit que
c'est un garçon
[Musique]
nous
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes c'est diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
on
[Musique]
oui ça pendant les deux premières années
nous avons voyagé à bord du dragon de
mer en cherchant les îles de plastique
en fait la superficie de l'océan est
dans sa majorité couverts d'une fine
couche de micro plastiques
ce qui me choque le plus je crois c'est
que nous n'avons jamais eu un chalut
vide
voilà ce que nous avons trouvé
aujourd'hui les filles c'est ce qui a
été retrouvé dans l'estomac d'un
albatros
cela ne peut pas être aussi nuisible
pour les petits poissons qui les mangent
vestes étroites fine mais le long de la
chaîne alimentaire cela peut atteindre
des niveaux nuisibles pour la santé
humaine
[Musique]
conte syrie l'onu met en garde contre le
péril imminent d'escada d'un conseil de
sécurité s'est tenu ce soir après
qu'ankara menacer damas d'une offensive
militaire imminente dans la province
d'idlib
la russie s'oppose à une déclaration
réclamant un cessez le feu et hausse le
ton vis-à-vis de la turquie
les dommages collatéraux de la sphère
griveaux avec ce règlement de comptes
entre anciens amis le patron du ps ni
l'effort accuse le ministre de
l'intérieur christophe castaner d'avoir
commis une faute grave en cause
l'évocation de sa vie privée et la radio
olivier faur demande à emmanuel macron
d'en tirer les conséquences
l'examen de la réforme des retraites
dire au blocage à l'assemblée nationale
au troisième jour des débats les rappels
au règlement et suspensions se succèdent
qu'antoinette cgt elle claque la porte
des discussions de la conférence sur le
financement ce que déplore l'exécutif
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez en direct sur rt france
doit-on craindre une escalade dans le
nord-ouest de la syrie
ce soir moscou s'est opposé à l'onu une
déclaration réclamant un cessez-le-feu
la turquie de son côté menace damas
d'une opération militaire imminente sur
est libre depuis plusieurs semaines les
milices soutenues par ankara affrontent
l'armée de bachar el assad
la tension est montée d'un cran après le
décès de militaires furent qu'après les
bombardements syriens ces menaces
interviennent alors que la russie alliée
de damas mène des négociations avec
ankara pour faire baisser les tensions
les discussions vaines pour le président
tueur de son côté le kremlin met en
garde contre toute opération visant
bachar al assad
nous entrons dans les derniers jours
pour le régime qui doit cesser son
offensive à idlib et se retirer aux
frontières de l'accord de sotchi c'est
notre dernière mise en garde
malheureusement ni les discussions et
dans notre pays et en russie ni les
négociations menées sur le terrain nous
nous ont permis d'obtenir le résultat
que nous voulons un charmant c'est le
cas pour le dire d'une manière plus
explicite
une opération à idlib est imminente nos
amis turcs n'ont pas réussi à séparer
les militants qui leur sont somistes des
terroristes dans le délai mentionné par
le mémorandum de septembre 2018
ils n'ont pas réussi à le faire un an
plus tard dans le même temps des
provocations depuis la zone dite libre
ont toujours lieu ainsi que des
bombardements visant les positions des
forces armées syriennes
des sites civils et la base aérienne
russe de facebook
naturellement les forces armées
syriennes tout en réitérant leur
attachement à l'accord initial qui
compris l'accord de cessez-le-feu
répondre à ces provocations
inacceptables et nous les soutenons
notre corps et l'odeur
l'émissaire de l'onu pour la série
mettant en garde aujourd'hui le conseil
de sécurité de l'onu contre un péril
imminent d'escala dans le dossier les
délégations russe et turc se sont réunis
à plusieurs reprises au cours des
derniers jours à ankara munich et moscou
il ya également eu des contacts au
niveau des présidents mais aucun accord
à ce stade n'a encore été conclu tout au
contraire les déclarations publiques des
différentes parties syriennes et
internationales l'est entendre un risque
imminent escalade expert en relais sur
international la russie pourrait dans
cette nouvelle escalade jouer un rôle de
modérateur
larbitre je ne sais pas mais sans doute
un régulateur et à modérateur
parce que évidemment la syrie est
l'alliée de la russie et la russie va
protéger la syrie mais la russie n'a pas
non plus intérêt à déclencher une
véritable catastrophe humanitaire et a
déclenché un déferlement de plus de deux
millions de réfugiés syriens sur la
turquie
ce hic très probablement les
réprobations internationales
alors c'est probablement ce qui fait
l'intérêt de la saisine du conseil de
sécurité aujourd'hui le statut de
réfugié de piotr pawlinski peut-il être
remis en cause c'est non pour les
services du ministère de l'intérieur
pour les éléments reprochés à l'artiste
russe ne peuvent être regardés comme
justifiant un retrait du statut le
ministre que sa mère lui juge au
contraire le gouvernement pourrait
remettre je me serais tu de piotr
pawlinski à l'issue de la procédure
judiciaire
une déclaration faite ce matin sur
france ô les éléments reprochés à piotr
pas plein ce qui ne peuvent être
regardés comme justifiant un retrait du
statut au sens de l'article l7 son 11-6
du code de l'entrée et du séjour des
étrangers et du droit d'asile
ce que j'attends d'eux quelqu'un que
l'on protège dans le cadre d'un statut
de réfugié politique
c'est qu'effectivement ils sont un
citoyen exemplaire s'il est sanctionné
nous pourrons remettre en cause son
statut de réfugié à ce moment là et
peut-on parler de la vie privée
hommes et femmes politiques ou s contre
les principes du débat public c'est la
question que le numéro un du parti
socialiste d'hiver fort a soulevé cet
après midi ce dernier a réagi aux propos
de christophe castaner tenus plus tôt
dans la journée les précisions de
cyrielle ben oui ils sont attendus ce
mercredi entre olivier faure et le
ministre de l'intérieur christophe
castaner en cause une déclaration du
premier secrétaire du parti socialiste
ce lundi au micro de france inter au
sujet de la sphère griveaux c'est la
preuve d'une légèreté incroyable parce
qu'aujourd'hui quand vous êtes un homme
ou une femme publique un décideur public
un ministre vous devez prendre toutes
les précautions d'usagé pour ne jamais
être à la portée des maîtres chanteurs
déclaration qui a déplu au ministre de
l'intérieur
ce dernier a riposté sur cette même
matinal ce mercredi matin en évoquant
directement à l'antenne la vie privée du
premier secrétaire du parti socialiste
les politiques doivent rester des femmes
et des hommes sinon ils se coupent de la
réalité j'ai été surpris d'entendre à
votre micro olivier faur que je connais
bien et que j'ai accompagné dans ses
divorces et séparations
j'ai été étonné de ces leçons de morale
il n'en fallait pas plus pour olivier
faure qui a convoqué une conférence de
presse ce mercredi après midi afin de
réagir aux propos du ministre de
l'intérieur
il en profite pour appeler le président
de la république à prendre des mesures
concernant christophe castaner ce matin
une ligne rouge a été franchie le fait
pour un ministre de l'intérieur de
chercher à intimider
l'un des dirigeants de l'opposition en
ayant recours à des insinuations
relevant de sa vie privée et d'une
atteinte au fondement même de la
démocratie
christophe castaner a commis une faute
grave
dès lors il appartient au président de
la république garant de nos institutions
de convoquer le ministre de l'intérieur
dans les meilleurs délais et d'en tirer
toutes les conséquences je vous remercie
personne une intervention qui n'a pas
laissé christophe castaner insensible le
poussant à réagir par le biais d'une
déclaration à la fp celui-ci a précisé
regretter ces propos
si l'on blessés olivier faure plus tôt
dans la journée de mercredi
le ministre de l'intérieur s'était
exprimé sur twitter cher olivier faure
il n'y avait ni menace ni attaques
personnelles dans mon propos nous nous
connaissons depuis assez longtemps pour
savoir l'un et l'autre que la vie n'est
pas linéaire et nous y avons quelquefois
fait face ensemble
reste désormais à savoir si emmanuel
macron décidera de réagir face à cette
nouvelle polémique provoquée par le
ministre français de l'intérieur et pour
denis demonpion éditorialiste politique
il s'agit surtout ici d'un règlement de
comptes entre deux socialistes
quand on observe maintenant les espèces
des changes de cour de récréation avec
olivier faure le premier secrétaire du
parti socialiste
alors ça aussi c'est vrai que ça un peu
agité les médias aujourd'hui
mais il faut ramener ça à sa juste
proportion c'est quoi au fond c'est une
sorte de règlement de compte entre deux
socialistes puisque monsieur castaner
était comme vous le savez membre du
parti socialiste
jusqu'à ce qu'ils fassent défection pour
rejoindre emmanuel macron à l'époque
olivier ce fort l'avait critiqué pour ça
pour avoir finalement fui le
l'embarcation alors qu'elle était en
train de couler et je pense que c'était
une manière assez peu élégante du
ministre de l'intérieur de lui renvoyer
la monnaie de sa pièce très selon un
sondage et lab les français déplorent la
diffusion des images à caractère privé
de benjamin griveaux deux tiers des
sondés pensent que piotr pas plein ce
qui n'aurait pas dû tenter ce type
d'action contre une personnalité
politique
parmi eux 78 % sont des électeurs des
manuels mais cran l'a fait un gris veau
et dans son sillage les propos de
christophe castaner sur le patron du
premier secrétaire du ps qui avait
dénoncé la veille la légèreté incroyable
de l'ancien candidat à la mairie de
paris écoutez les réactions venues de
l'étranger
nous on a eu du malheur vous avez parlé
des îles et la victime c'est vrai il est
la victime parce que la loi dit qu'il
est et il est victime et en espagne on a
eu du mal aussi à défendre le fait qu'il
soit la victime dont les sources qu'il
n'aurait pas eu des cas griveaux s'il
n'y avait pas eu des vidéos persos lui
avait des bons d'aidé
istres ce type de vidéos et de l'envoyer
sachant le risque que ça peut nous poser
pour un homme politique dont cadum
public qui ont plus à l'époque il était
ministre il était même pas candidat
l'époque il était ministre
donc c'est encore plus plus plus plus
plus compliqué et puis il faut pas non
plus oublier que la france part et kid
cudi que découvre la sphère griveaux
mais on oublie qu'il y a quelques années
il ya eu quelque chose de semblable
honfleur en france c'était le cas
valbuena avec karim benzema une vidéo
aussi sexuel qui a été publié et qui a
eu des gants même dans le procès n'a pas
encore vraiment terminée ou lyon ont
fait qui va avoir lieu
donc ce n'est pas la première fois que
ça arrive et nous on a été surpris des
devoirs comme en france on prenait ça
comme si c'était la première fois bas
non non c'est pas la première fois que
je pense que l'état on a moins de
problèmes mais pas s'occuper de moeurs
bien que c'est une attitude comment dire
bien pensante
on a eu aussi politiques qui ont étalé
leur vie familiale avec l'italie a été
longtemps elle est un peu moins mais
elle a été longtemps un pays très
catholique donc les hommes et femmes
politiques ont souvent présenté leur
modèle familial comme un modèle de la
famille parfaite mère des problèmes
derrière et un premier sondage sur les
municipales parisiennes depuis le
retrait de benjamin griveaux pas
d'effets busan notable pour le moment la
désormais ex ministre de la santé
candidate la république en marche on
obtient tout de même 17 % des intentions
de vote au premier tour pointent à la
troisième place
à noter la percée de rachida dati qui
grimpe de 5 points par rapport au mois
précédent de son côté la socialiste anne
hidalgo reste stable à 23 % au second
tour l'hypothèse d'une alliance entre
socialistes et écologistes remporterait
la mise
l'assemblée nationale poursuit ou plutôt
tente de poursuivre ses débats sur le
projet de réforme des retraites sur les
plus de quarante mille amendements
déposés en majorité par la france
insoumise et des communistes
les députés n'ont étudié que quelques 80
amendements tous ont été rejetés
et cette bataille ouverte entre majorité
et opposition va encore durer au moins
deux semaines la porte parole du
gouvernement restent elles évasif quant
à une utilisation du 49 3 comme vous le
savez le 49-3 est un outil
constitutionnel et à ce stade la
constitution n'a pas bougé sauf erreur
de ma part la volonté du gouvernement
est évidemment que nous puissions avoir
un débat un débat qui soit le plus
serein possible mais vous aurez remarqué
qu'il n'est pas de notre fait mais de
celui de la france insoumise et du
groupe gdr à l'assemblée nationale qu'il
y ait cette forme d'obstruction qui au
fond ne sert pas vraiment le débat et
qui conduit y compris à ce qu'il y ait
des prises de positions étonnantes
notamment de la part de la france
insoumise lorsque nous trouvons des
amendements de suppression pour qu'il
n'y ait pas de minimum de pension
accordée aux retraités en france
il ya un certain nombre d'organisations
politiques qui ne souhaite pas qu'il y
ait un débat et qui souhaitent
simplement empêcher que cette réforme
puisse avoir lieu
et même empêché un débat démocratique
qui contribuent à éclairer nos
concitoyens de manière collective
mais l'opposition continue de contester
cette réforme des retraites marine le
pen jean-luc mélenchon ou encore nicolas
dupont aignan il évoque tous le recours
aux 49 3 la majorité des français sont
opposés à cette réforme des retraites
donc ils gouvernent contre le peuple
français
si évidemment il passe par le 49-3 alors
même que déjà le recours à 29 ordonnance
est un abus manifeste bien entendu je
pense que ce sera entendu par les
français comme un nouvel acte de
d'autoritarisme veulent que ce soit le
chaos et qu'on puisse dire c'est
l'opposition qui a créé le chaos donc 49
3 au 7 49 3 il n'y a pas beaucoup de
pays où ça existe un truc pareil
je voudrais rappeler à tout le monde ce
que ça veut dire le gouvernement dit
article 49 3
si vous n'avez pas de majorité contre le
gouvernement salue le texte est adopté
non mais ce qui se passe est ahurissant
mais je je j'ai déposé une centaine
d'amendements donc je ne suis pas celui
qui dépose des milliers d'amendements
mais on n'a pas le droit on n'a jamais
vu un président de l'assemblée nationale
se comportait comme un chef de parti
voilà la réalité le président de
l'assemblée nationale outrepasse ses
droits et s'appuie sur une décision du
conseil constitutionnel en
l'interprétant à sa façon et en
exagérant son pouvoir
ils font porter sur le groupe communiste
le poids de leur haine de classe leur
volonté de déchirer ce qui fait le socle
de la protection sociale à la française
ils ont décidé de pourrir nos retraites
nous allons leur pourrir le débat
l'hémicycle est un lieu de confrontation
et de confrontation notamment d'idées
donc les moyens aussi pour retarder les
débats sont souvent employées d'ailleurs
ils sont régulés par le règlement
simplement un règlement utiliser de fait
sont pas claires un texte chaotique
ça crée une séance chaotique et or en
réalité c'est ce qu'on a vécu cet après
midi qui peut penser qu'en deux ou trois
semaines on va réussir à discuter d'un
système de retraite qui chamboule
absolument la totalité du système de
retraites le connaissent les français et
nous nous portons aussi un contre-projet
qui est sérieux qui est financée qui
fait la démonstration qui n'est pas
juste que le seul poids de l'effort pèse
sur les travailleurs par le fait de
devoir travailler toujours plus
longtemps sauf à voir sa pension
diminuer en quelque sorte son niveau de
pension diminuée et côté syndical alors
que la conférence de financement vient
seulement de débuter la cgt quitte la
table des négociations catherine perret
numéro deux du syndicat l'a annoncé ce
matin sur radio classique
elle a évoqué un compromis impossible
une annonce à laquelle a aussitôt réagi
laurent empiétera 16 qui le secrétaire
d'état chargé des retraites
la conférence des financements est morte
le compromis n'est pas possible on n'a
plus rien à faire à cette conférence des
financements par contre on va organiser
notre propre conférence
il n'y a pas que la cgt dans le paysage
syndical français
je regrette toujours que les partenaires
sociaux veulent pas au bout des temps
des opportunités qui leur sont offertes
pour henri sterdyniak économiste au
centre de recherche en économie de
sciences po membres des économistes
atterrés la cgt n'est pas prête à
préconiser de nouvelles mesures disons
que cette conférence de financement
n'avait pas grand sens pour la sage la
cgt puisque le gouvernement l'avait
organisé avec que le diktat qu' il
fallait absolument que les partenaires
sociaux se trouvent se mettre d'accord
pour récupérer 12 milliards en 2017 à
2027 l'évaluation que le gouvernement
faisait du déficit prévisible dans la
mesure où la cgt estime que ce déficit
prévisible n'existe pas dans la mesure
où la cgt n'est pas prêt à prendre des
mesures a préconisé des mesures pour
réduire
les retraites pour retarder l'âge de
départ à la retraite pour économiser ses
12 milliards effectivement la cgt avait
pas grand chose à faire dans cette
conférence aux états unis le
milliardaire michael bloomberg fera son
entrée en piste ce soir face à ses
rivaux démocrates pour l'investiture à
la présidentielle premier débat télévisé
pour celui qui se présente comme le
candidat capable de rassembler au centre
retour sur son ascension fulgurante avec
clémence pital les analystes politiques
ne lui donnait aucune chance
pourtant trop mois plus tard michael
bloomberg en course à l'investiture
démocrate à bondy en troisième position
des sondages et on tombe bien défier
donald trump
je me présente pour vaincre donald trump
j'avais averti dans mon discours à la
convention démocrate en 2016 à
philadelphie que 2 valve trump n'était
pas apte à occuper cette fonction
et il est bien pire que ce que j'avais
imaginé pour rattraper son retard
l'ancien maire de new york a dépensé
sans compter plus de 400 millions de
dollars dans une campagne publicitaire
devenu presque omniprésente dans le pays
de quoi inquiéter ses concurrents alors
qu'il talonne les favoris démocrate joe
biden et bernie sanders ses adversaires
ou double leurs attaques
il accuse ainsi le septuagénaire de
chercher à acheter la présidentielle est
dénoncée choix politiques parfois très
conservateur monsieur bloomberg
vous n'allez certainement pas gagner
lorsqu'on sait qu'à new york vous avez
mené une politique raciste
quelques le stop et fritz
et oblige les communautés minoritaires
les afro américains et latino américain
à vivre dans la peur et l'humiliation
dans la ville de new york
vous n'avez pas gagné l'élection
si vous opposé à l'augmentation du
salaire minimum vous savez les gens qui
ont des milliards de dollars ne devrait
pas s'opposer une augmentation du
salaire minimum au dessus de 7 $ 25 de
leur île charge de sanders alors que le
milliardaire n'a cessé d'osciller entre
les familles démocrate et républicaine
au gré de ses ambitions politiques
michael bloomberg est poursuivi par sa
politique de contrôles policiers
systématiques ne stoppant risque
décision qu'il a déploré deux semaines
avant de se lancer dans la course à la
présidentielle
ils viennent approche que je regrette
profondément
l'abus d'une pratique policière appelée
stop and fisc je vais défendu pendant
trop longtemps car je ne comprenais pas
alors la douleur à justifier qu'elles
causaient aux jeunes familles noires et
métisses ainsi qu'à leurs enfants
j'aurais dû agir plus tôt et plus
rapidement pour y mettre fin
je n'ai pas fait et je me suis excusé
alors que michael bloomberg entend
rassembler l'électorat démocrate modérée
la course à l'investiture semble encore
très ouverte
le milliardaire va participer
aujourd'hui à son premier débat dans le
nevada état où sera organisé samedi le
troisième vote pour la primaire et pour
françois durpaire historien spécialiste
des etats-unis le plus intéressant dans
ce les masses et l'arrivée de bloomberg
dans la course
c'est pas un débat général c'est pas un
débat national c'est un débat où on a
les yeux tournés vers le nevada et à
leur prochaine les issues donc on va
vraiment aimé vallat c'est assez ouvert
parce qu'on n'a pas énormément de
sondages traditionnellement c'est un
état on a petit nuage et où
effectivement c'est assez ouvert c'est à
dire qu'on n'a pas encore ce duel tant
annoncé
on a effectivement un candidat qui est
favori parce que il est bien maintenant
une avance à deux chiffres il a 31 %
c'est sanders mais en même temps il est
socialiste est ce que ça va aller
jusqu'au bout c'est quand même assez
étonnant puis alors évidemment l'inconnu
la nuit c'est l'arrivée de bloomberg
dans la course c'est la première fois
qu'on va le voir le milliardaire l'homme
qui valait 50 7 milliards de dollars
c'est c'est ça qui va être intéressant
parce que dépenser d'argent est une
chose faire des pubs pré enregistré et
balancé à la télé à la radio 300
millions $ quand même dépensé c'est une
chose mais être en débat c'en est une
autre touriste étudiants main d'oeuvre
dès demain plus aucun ressortissant
chinois ne pourra entrer en russie des
mesures sanitaires prises contre le
nouveau coronavirus les précisions dylan
affaires indien la russie ferme ses
portes aux chinois ce décret vise à
empêcher sur le territoire us la
propagation du nouveau coronavirus aussi
appelé kovy 19
selon cette mesure temporaire il sera
seulement permis aux chinois de
transiter via la russie
concrètement ils pourront faire une
simple escale vers ou à partir de
l'europe
une décision motivée par de nouveaux
chiffres annoncés par pékin why
actuellement 57 1805 cas diagnostiqués
dont 11 1977 cas sévères il ya un total
de quatorze 1376 qu'à soigner est sorti
de l'hôpital il y un total de 2004 cas
de mort à cause du virus
si officiellement il n'y a plus aucun
malades touchés par le virus en russie
moscou reste néanmoins très préoccupés
par la menace sanitaire
il y a quelques jours déjà les liaisons
ferroviaires avaient été coupés et le
nombre de vols vers des villes chinoises
restreint des mesures radicales qui ont
provoqué de lourdes conséquences sur le
plan économique
l'industrie du voyage est ainsi
fortement impactée en russie car le
marché chinois reste un des premiers
vivier du tourisme en 2019 2,3 millions
de citoyens chinois sont ainsi entrés en
russie dont 1,5 million de touristes et
plus de 320 milles pour des voyages
d'affaires
les groupes constitués environ 80 % du
flux touristiques en provenance de chine
autrement dit le flux s'était asséchée
et désormais il est figé
bien sûr les pertes sont colossales mais
elles concernent avant tout les
entrepreneurs chinois
au delà du secteur touristique la russie
risque aussi
souffrir d'un problème de main d'oeuvre
car les chinois sont notamment très
présent dans les grands projets de
construction et l'importation de
produits de consommation
mais la mesure reste provisoire dans le
reste du monde
la propagation du virus semble toujours
sous contrôle
l'afghanistan face à une impasse
politique selon les résultats définitifs
de la commission électorale indépendante
le président sortant ashraf ghani a
obtenu plus de 50% des voix et donc
réélu à la tête du pays et son
adversaire historique abdullah abdullah
ne l'entend pas de cette oreille ils
estiment que la commission électorale
n'a aucune légitimité
ashraf ghani compte s'appuyer sur sa
victoire pour relancer les négociations
avec les talibans ce n'est pas seulement
une victoire lors d'une élection c'est
aussi la victoire de la république
islamique d'afghanistan avec courage et
stratégie nous ferons avancer les
négociations de paix mais ce sera la
nation afghane qui prendra la décision
finale
il n'y aura pas de décision cachée à ce
sujet les chiffres annoncés aujourd'hui
sont ceux d'une fraude électorale d'un
coup d'état contre la démocratie d'une
trahison de la volonté du peuple et de
nous considérons comme illégal depuis sa
fondation sur la base de votre propre et
biométriques
le parti de la stabilité et de la
convergence et le gagnant de cette
élection et nous annonçons notre
victoire
deux candidats qui revendiquent donc la
victoire une crise politique qui se
dessine alors que pensent les afghans de
cette élection présidentielle quel bilan
pour ashraf ghani éléments de réponse l'
annonce des résultats donnent un nouveau
message au peuple
est destinée à ceux qui ont dirigé le
peuple pendant 40 ans et imposé la
guerre civile j'ai l'espoir que notre
pays se dirige progressivement vers la
paix tout le monde a attendu pendant
cinq mois
l'activité économique s'est arrêtée en
raison des élections quand la tenant que
les résultats de l'élection sont
annoncés nous aspirons la paix plus que
les résultats de l'élection
mon opinion est que ashraf ghani a
fourni des services publics un filet
très beau travailler à construire des
infrastructures aux puciers au président
est réélu sous la montre qu'il a fait du
très bon travail et que le peuple
satisfaits et donc il y en aurait on
écoute maintenant l'analyse de david de
rigoler rose chercheur à l'iris et alips
un des griefs justement du président
sera fera ni c'est d'avoir été jusqu'à
présent un peu laissé à la marge des
négociations directes entre les talibans
et les américains le processus de ces
négociations s'est poursuivie d'une
certaine manière sans la balle et
parfois même sur les consultations en
tout cas pas a priori du gouvernement
afghan
il n'en reste pas moins que les
américains ont besoin quand même d'un
gouvernement qui soit susceptible de
négocier après dans le cadre d'un
dialogue intriguant puisque dans les
négociations de doha ont été prévus
trois étapes en fait la première est un
cessez le feu qui serait une mesure de
confiance demandé par les américains sur
une semaine et à l'issue de cette mesure
de confiance si le cessez le feu était
effectif il y aurait la possibilité
effectivement d'aller vers la signature
d'un accord dont les paramètres ont été
déjà assez largement des établis entre
les deux parties avec une troisième
étape justement qu'il poserait la
question du droit du dialogue intra
afghan qui est une nécessité pour
aboutir et finaliser ce processus et
c'est là où on retrouve effectivement la
crise actuelle c'est la fin de ce
journal merci de l'avoir suivi prochain
rendez-vous avec l'actualité ce sera
demain matin 7 heures
du matin heure française excès en fin de
soirée at-on su r d france
[Musique]
c'est le sentiment que vous avez eue
vous aussi ce besoin d'autonomie
oui complètement besoin d'autonomie
besoin de retourner à des choses plus
essentielles en fait est vraiment de
sentir qu'on n'est pas forcément un
poids pour la planète
il ya une idée derrière il ya une
philosophie aussi qu'on a vu la serre
les plantes poussent le fait de vivre
avec les plantes comme ça vraiment
commune comme une machine un organisme
pour faire partie de cet organisme
on a eu vraiment l'impression de se
construire en même temps qu'on vous
construisez cette maison en faisant
toutes ces rencontres et je pense que
ces genres de projets qui se fait pas
tout seul dans son coin on est dans un
truc vraiment de coopération de partage
de partage